Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Oh, Gürs.
So, ich war jetzt ein paar Tage nicht mehr on.
Aber Sonntag morgens da geht ja nicht ohne Streamsorten.
Wir machen auch vielleicht heute Abend oder morgen, ich muss mal gucken.
Aber den zweiten Teil vom Web-Applikation KEC WSService einrichten.
Was ist einrichten?
Zertifikate ausstellen, Deployen auf Linux Server automatisieren.
Entweder machen wir das heute Mittag oder wir machen das morgen irgendwann.
Ich hab mir schon ein paar Sachen überlegt, was wir da machen.
Geht's dir wieder gut nach der Info?
Ja, das einzige, was noch ist, ist, also ich hatte saumäßig Kopfweh.
Das war wirklich nervig.
Und mir hat der Arm wehgetan.
Arm ist jetzt nur noch ein bisschen, wenn ich direkt da draufdrücke, wo es hin gespritzt hat.
Ansonsten ist eigentlich alles wieder gut.
Passt ja noch vom letzten Stream.
Ja, passt noch.
Leute, ich muss mal kurz mein Headset raus und wieder reinmachen.
Ups, alles klar.
Ist übrigens genau passiert, bei mir war das die zweite Dosis.
Ich hab jetzt die zweite Antenne bekommen, den anderen Arm.
Jetzt ist der Empfang auch wirklich gut.
Aber es ist genau das passiert, was ich in einem der letzten Streams gesagt hab, wie es laufen wird.
Was ich witzig fand, dass es auch so genau gestimmt hat.
Und zwar, wir hatten es ja in einem der letzten Stream von, soll man die Leute zum Impfen zwingen,
also sprich, soll man die Leute zu ihrem Glück zwingen oder was weiß ich,
sollen sie die Leute verbieten, irgendwo hinzugehen.
Und ich hatte in dem Stream gesagt, so mehr oder weniger wortwörtlich,
die ganzen Läden haben ja überhaupt kein Interesse dran,
irgendwie Leute davon abzuhalten, bei ihnen einzukaufen oder bei ihnen Dienstleistungen in Anspruch zu nehmen.
Egal, ob sie jetzt dazu angehalten werden oder nicht.
Die haben überhaupt kein Interesse drin, die wollen den Scheiß verkaufen.
Ich muss gestern zum Friseur.
Und in Hessen, hier in dieser Region, haben wir jetzt wieder über einem gewissen Wert,
das heißt, ich müsste eigentlich, eigentlich, müsste ich geimpft sein, getestet sein oder genesen sein.
So, dann bin ich gestern zum Friseur gegangen, also ich hab extra vorher mal nachgeguckt.
Und ich wurde ja erst vorgestern geimpft.
Das bedeutet, eigentlich hätte der Friseur mir sagen müssen, entweder machst du einen Test,
zeigst mir deinen gescannten QR-Code-Impf aus, aber alles sonst was.
Oder, oder, dass du Corona schon überstanden hast.
Aber, was hat der Friseur gemacht?
Ich bin rein, hab gesagt, hier muss ich mich nicht irgendwo eintragen, dass ich da gewesen bin.
Sagt sie, nö, nö, ich blicke da mittlerweile eh nicht mehr durch, äh, setz dich einfach hin.
Das ist genau das, was ich gesagt hab.
Und ich kann es da auch keinem Laden übel nehmen, dass da mittlerweile immer noch, dass, dass, äh, nicht mehr gemacht wird.
Das ändert sich laufend.
Und dazu kommt, dass, dass die Unternehmen da überhaupt kein Interesse daran haben, so was durchzusetzen.
Warum? Was wäre, ich mein, was wäre für den Friseur dann die Alternative gewesen?
Zu sagen, ja, okay, dann komm ich halt in 14 Tagen wieder.
Äh, weil dann bist du, also du giltst ja nicht mit der zweiten Impfung als geimpft, sondern erst nach 14 Tagen oder so.
Dass genau das passiert, exakt so, wie ich mir das gedacht hab.
Nur, dass das jetzt so schnell, dass ich das jetzt so schnell selbst dafür eigentlich nicht gedacht hab.
Aber dem war das scheißegal.
Verständlicherweise.
Ähm, die hatten schon genug Probleme das letztes Jahr über.
ProGame, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ai jaja, hier riecht huge, cute, cute Emotes.
So, und jetzt bei dieser Gelegenheit möchte ich mal noch auf was anderes.
Was in Österreich musst du 22 Tage nach der ehemaligen letzten Impfung warten.
Doch bei uns sind's 14 Tage.
Ist mir auch wurscht.
Ich hab' jetzt mal'n Stempel im Impfausweis und ich hab die QR Codes.
Josh, Dankeschön!
Brr grr grr grr grr grr.
Rit, Glint, Glint, Glint, Glint Prima Gaming's Up
Euhm
Ich habe es jetzt überstanden, ich habe mein Eintrag im Impfausweis und ich habe die QR-Codes und dann ist gut
Wenn jetzt noch irgendwie einer will
Zeige ich ihm mein Impfausweis, wo irgendwie das mir
Dann ist Ruhe, ja
Und wenn dann immer noch einer nicht will
Dass ich, ähm
In das Geschäft gehe, dann gehe ich da halt nicht hin
Dann haben sie halt Pech
Irgendwann ist auch mal gut.
Naja, ich möchte jetzt noch mal schnell auf was anderes aufmerksam machen.
Erstmal gucken, wer haben wir denn hier am Start? Der Sarix ist wieder da.
Oh Leute, lasst euch jebaiten.
Ich merke gerade, ein bisschen Kopfweh habe ich immer noch.
Aber es hält sich in Grenzen.
Lasst euch mal ein bisschen jebaiten von Twitch.
Ich weiß, in der Woche nicht mehr streamen,
sind die ganzen Subzahlen runtergegangen.
Wir müssen, glaube ich, nachher mal eine Runde Subscription raten machen.
Lasst euch mal ein bisschen jebaiten.
Oder lasst euch mal eine Runde scammen.
Hey, es war noch nie so günstig,
sich vom Scamtrain scammen zu lassen.
Anstatt 5 Euro nur noch 4 Euro jetzt.
Also ich meine,
wer lässt sich da nicht, gern mal jebaiten von Twitch.
Jeff braucht, dass er in seiner Rakete ins Weltall fliegen kann.
Siehste, easy, bam.
100 Billionen.
Josh, nice, danke.
So, wen haben wir denn hier? Der Sarix ist am Start.
Hirbel.
Das Stripe ist natürlich wieder bei Stripe,
auch wieder am Start. Oh, der Nightbot, wer ist das denn?
Ja, okay.
Give to Payne's Champions.
Ja, Enrixel ist auch wieder da.
Kangin, Stubenhocker,
Ed, Benister,
Sunclasses and Soda.
Wisst ihr an was mich das erinnert?
Kennt noch jemand Epic Mealtime?
Also als sie noch Epic waren
und nicht irgendwie zu so einer 15 langweiligen
Show geworden sind, wie sie es jetzt waren?
Wie sie es jetzt sind.
Kennt noch einer Epic Mealtime, wo
der Typ mit der Sonnenbrille und den Muskeln
immer am Start war? Baconstraps, genau.
10G.
Naja, bei Wi-Fi
sind wir ja fast schon, also wir sind jetzt
bei Wi-Fi 6.
Das bedeutet, bald gibt es
6G, aber das ist dann
6 Gigahertz W-Lan gibt es demnächst.
Das ist eh verwirrend. Es gibt 5G,
das ist 5th Generation
Mobilfunk, dann gibt es
3G, 3G
ist eigentlich LTE,
ne, Moment, ist 3G
LTE,
doch, 3G ist LTE, ne.
Es gibt 3G LTE,
wobei hingegen 3G bei
Corona ja auch getestet,
genesen oder geimpft ist.
4G ist LTE,
3G ist ja noch, ne,
UMTS, das davor
war 3G, genau,
ja, ja, ihr habt recht.
Davor gab es noch Edge
und sonst was.
3G, allerdings
5G ist Mobile,
5 Gigahertz ist
W-Lan, Wi-Fi 6
ist teilweise
5 Gigahertz W-Lan
und bald kommt Wi-Fi
6E heißt das glaube ich,
mit 6 Gigahertz,
da blickt keiner mehr durch, da blickt
niemand, das ist vorbei.
Das sieht unter die Check keiner mehr.
Eichst, danke schön hier,
der Hype Train geht rauf, ich sehe schon.
Danke für den Sub.
Soxy,
der Josh, der Brezelsnacker
hat auch Subscribed,
Dankeschön, habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Alle sind sie da hier, nice.
Übrigens,
genau das habe ich auch erlebt,
ich war in Frankfurt bei Mexicana,
letztens, als ich mal wieder in Frankfurt war,
ich war bei Mexicana,
war an der Kasse und die haben gemeint,
ja hier, scannen sie mal den QR-Code
und füllen sie das aus.
Crackford, genau.
Ich habe den QR-Code gescannt,
leider den falschen, die sind ja auch
bescheuert, die haben einen QR-Code hingestellt,
direkt daneben haben sie ihren QR-Code für
Werbung für den Laden hingestellt.
Also die haben so eine Gutscheinaktion,
da kannst du einen QR-Code scannen
und die haben den QR-Code für Corona
und die stehen direkt nebeneinander
und ich habe erstmal den QR-Code für die Gutscheinaktion
gescannt ausversehen, da ist das
Hä, Moment, warum geht das nicht?
Dann habe ich den QR-Code gescannt
für Corona,
habe mich dann draußen hingesetzt
und als ich auf dem Weg zurück war,
ist mir eingefallen, oh, ich habe jetzt ganz vergessen
auszufüllen, das war jetzt, da muss ich tatsächlich
keine Absicht, ich habe einfach nicht dran gedacht,
aber als ich dann auf dem Rückweg war, haben sie mir gesagt,
komm, scheiß drauf, jetzt ist es auch egal.
Wie gesagt,
das ist genau das, was ich gesagt habe, es interessiert
einfach niemand mehr.
Interessiert auch wirklich keinen.
Ich muss dir sagen,
ich habe noch nicht mal eine Corona App
auf dem Handy, ich habe keine Corona
App, weil ich früher, also
als das, was heißt früher, als diese
ganze Corona Geschichte angefangen hat,
hatte ich noch ein iPhone 6, war das
glaube ich, oder ein
6S, ich weiß es nicht,
ich hatte ein iPhone, was keine Updates mehr
bekommt und dementsprechend keine
Corona App installieren kann, sonst hätte ich das gemacht.
Mittlerweile habe ich ja ein neues
11er, da könnte ich das machen,
aber ich hatte eh Dauer Home Office
und habe mir gedacht, du weißt was,
in die Nähe von anderen Leuten will ich eh nicht,
scheiß drauf.
Und jetzt habe ich es auch nicht mehr installiert.
Du könntest den Kollegen hausten, wenn er
zockt, ich hauste eigentlich gar keine
Leute so automatisch,
sondern immer nur nach dem Stream,
wenn es irgendwie einen gibt, den ich selbst
follower, der wenig Zuschauer
hat, der das irgendwie braucht.
Alkes, danke für den Sub.
GSM, Edge,
UMTS, LTE, 5G, stimmt.
5G hat auch manchmal 5 Gigahertz,
das stimmt. 5G ist es nicht 10?
10 Gigahertz eigentlich?
Ach, ich blicke da aus dem Kopf nicht mal
durch.
Benzel, danke
für den Sub. Wird das echt noch benutzt?
Weiß ich nicht. Was denn?
Keine Ahnung. Also die App habe ich
ernsthaft noch nie.
Klippt das Audio?
Moment. Klippt? Nee, da klippt
eigentlich nichts. Es ist sogar
ein bisschen leise.
Moment.
Warte mal, mein Mikro
ist ein bisschen leise, oder?
Ein bisschen leiser als sonst.
Oder nicht? Oder doch?
Warte mal, ich muss mal kurz hören, ob das
klippt.
Klippt das Audio?
Wenn das jetzt nicht klippt, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Also es sieht auf jeden Fall nicht
so aus, als würde es klippen.
Weil wenn es klippt, würde es hier nicht
höher gehen. Und es würde
immer oben hängen. Nee.
Nee, macht es nicht.
Was ich aber nicht verstehe, ist
warum ist denn
so leise heute?
Noise Filter, Noise Gain?
Habe ich die Lautstärke falsch
eingestellt oder so? Weil es
ist doch leiser als sonst. Wobei,
ist es leiser als sonst?
Vielleicht schrei ich nicht
so rum wie sonst.
Keine Ahnung.
Nee, es ist exakt
so wie immer.
Es ist genau so. Aber es ist
leiser. Es ist leiser.
Das ist wieder so die typischen
Windows Audio
Settings.
Wo du keine Ahnung hast,
warum das leiser
ist. Ich habe nichts
geändert. Nix. Gar nichts.
Am ganzen OBS nicht, an den
Windows Settings nicht, an meinem
Computer nicht.
Gar nichts.
Wenn ich die Gain ausmache, ist es
viel, viel leiser. Hä? Moment.
Warum ist das hier? Blablabla.
Ja, doch. Ist schon ein Unterschied.
Okay, keine Ahnung. Ich mache jetzt
einfach mal einen Ticken
lauter und dann ist es jetzt
exzellent.
Wunderbar.
Die Katze war upstream.
Ja, genau.
Das wird es gewesen sein.
Windows Logik, ja. Verstehe nicht.
Also.
Kannst du das mit 5G,
4G, 6G und so weiter mal erklären?
Also das ganz einfach. 6G gibt es nicht.
6G wäre dann, also wenn man
von Mobilfunk redet,
wäre 6G der Nachfolger von
5G. Aber nachdem wir gerade mal
5G am Ausbauen sind, wird 6G noch
ein bisschen dauern. Das sind einfach
Generation. Erste Generation
habe ich keine Ahnung, was das war.
Erste Generation war Edge.
Dritte Generation war
UMTS. Vierte Generation
war LTE. Fünfte Generation
ist halt 5G,
was ein ziemlich bescheuerter Name ist. Aber okay.
Es
heißt bestimmt auch eigentlich irgendwie anders nach.
Erste Generation war nur GSM.
GSM, stimmt.
Ja, das gab es ja auch noch. So.
Und
das ist, wenn es um Mobilfunk geht.
Was ich jetzt gemeint habe, was halt noch
ein bisschen verwirrend ist, ist, wenn man dann auch die ganzen
WLAN-Geschichten dabei nimmt.
Zum Beispiel das
5 Gigahertz
WLAN, ja nicht 5G.
Und WIFI 6
ist ein WIFI-Standard,
der eigentlich IEEE
802.11ax heißt.
Den man einfach nur WIFI 6
genannt hat. Demnächst
kommt WIFI 6E, was
selbst unter anderem 6 Gigahertz
WLAN unterstützt. Wohlgemerkt,
5 Generation Mobilfunk
ist nicht zwangsläufig 5 auf 5
Gigahertz. Das ist einfach,
wenn man WLAN und mobile Sachen in einen
Topf speist, dann ist die Verwirrung
groß. Das ist eigentlich alles, was ich sagen wollte.
Ja, wundert mich auch nicht.
Aktuell ist 5G 2 bis 3,4 Gigahertz.
Ja, es ist, es ist halt
wenn man das zusammenschmeißt,
es blickt keiner mehr durch.
Ritter, Wurst, Dankeschön, für den Zap.
Massive, 2 Monate.
Was?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich brauche keine Verified Mail.
Das liegt nicht an Twitch.
Das liegt
eindeutig an den Windows-Settings, wo
ich echt keinen Plan habe,
also
was Microsoft da treibt.
Warum, wie, ich habe ehrlich gesagt
legit keinen Plan, wie es sein kann,
dass der Sound von heute auf morgen anders ist,
obwohl exakt alles genau so
eingestellt ist wie vorher.
Das ist ja gar nicht mehr so schlimm.
Also mittlerweile gibt es ja tatsächlich
doch halbwegs brauchbare
Mobilfunk-Tarife. Also es ist jetzt nicht
mal wie vor 3, 4 Jahren, wo ich da immer
quasi jeden zweiten Stream drüber geflammt habe
oder so.
Das ist Mobilfunk. Das ist Mobilfunk.
5G ist Mobilfunk. Nicht zu verwechseln eben
wie gesagt mit 5 Gigahertz WLAN.
5 Gigahertz WLAN
gibt es ab
ähm
ich glaube ab dem vorletzten WLAN-Standard.
Also 802.11
AC?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
AC!
Leute, ich hatte recht. Big Brain Time.
AC.
So, also ich möchte
ich möchte jetzt mal auf eine Sache hinweisen,
Leute.
Den, den, den cutesten
Chat von allen
möchte ich auf eine Sache hinweisen und zwar
ich habe heute morgen auf Twitter folgendes gesehen
von der Katzenhilfe Karlsruhe.
Die haben geschrieben, dass sie
unbedingt... Twitter.
Twitter willst du mich verarschen? Ich darf den Tweet
nicht aufmachen.
Gut, Twitter möchte
nicht, dass ich denen irgendwie helfe.
Alles klar. Zumindest die Katzenhilfe
Karlsruhe hat geschrieben sie brauchen Nachschub
alles
mögliche von
unterschiedlichem Futter bis
ihre Sachen auf der Amazon-Wunschliste
und sonst wie. Und
ich finde die machen das ein bisschen unglücklich. Die müssten
hier ganz fett den Paypal...
Die müssten sowohl hier als auch hier den ganz
fett den
Paypal Donation
Button machen.
Ah guck, ich krieg's grad geschickt.
Die müssten ganz fett den Paypal Donation
Button machen.
Dass man direkt
Paypal überweisen kann. Also
falls irgendjemand
falls euch das in irgendeiner
Art und Weise wichtig ist, euch das
berührt oder wie auch immer, dann könnt ihr euch
ja mal überlegen, ob ihr nicht der Katzenhilfe
Karlsruhe ein paar Euro dalasst.
Ihr müsst ja nicht Amazon-Wunschliste, ihr müsst
auch kein Futter
hinschicken
oder sonst
was.
Ihr könnt denen einfach was
über Paypal überweisen. Entweder direkt hier drüber
oder sie haben hier bei Spenden
auch die ganze Sache stehen. Ich hab das
vorhin auch gemacht.
Ich hab den vorhin 300 Euro überwiesen.
Einfach Paypal einloggen,
draufklicken
und auf die
das als Empfänger eingeben.
Und dann was
ihr wollt.
Aber ich wollte das jetzt einfach nur nochmal
zeigen, dass man sieht,
dass auch das eingedreht ist, was ich im
Video gesagt hab, dass gerade
nach Corona oder wenn Corona
wieder abappt, dass dann die Leute
ihre ganzen Haustiere, die sie sich geholt
haben, die hier jetzt
vielleicht nicht, die sind da viel zu jung für,
aber generell ist es ja bei denen auch
voll und platzt aus allen Nähten.
Was genau das passiert ist, was ich im Video gesagt
hab, dass die Leute, das war ja auch klar im Vorfeld,
dass die Leute, die sich jetzt ihre Haustiere
geholt haben, bei Corona festgestellt haben
Fuck, wir haben gar keine Zeit für Haustiere.
Wenn wir so wieder auf die Arbeit fahren,
sind einen halben Tag unterwegs, was auch immer, Hunde,
was die Leute sich da sonst noch holen,
Meerschweinchen, hast du nicht gesehen, dass sie jetzt
alles wieder zurück
ähm
geben,
so als könnte man das umtauschen.
Dementsprechend, die Tierheime sind so voll wie nie.
Wenn jetzt da noch ein paar Babys dazu
kommen, dann ist natürlich, dann platzt
dann platzt alles, ja.
Akor,
Alter, gibt's das auch noch.
So, zumindest das wollte ich jetzt mal zeigen.
Und dann noch was anderes.
Und auch was anderes hat jetzt mit Katzen und
Tierheimen und so gar nichts zu tun.
Wisst ihr, ich hab heute Morgen eine sehr interessante
Sicherheitslücke entdeckt, auf
Bitter
hat einer gepostet, der Johnhead
hat das gepostet, und zwar
oh, der hat einen Big Brain Bash
Einzeiler, als
Profil.
Und zwar hat er rausgefunden,
ich zeig euch gleich das Video, das ist eigentlich
richtig geil, betrifft jeden Windows Rechner.
Er hat rausgefunden,
wenn man eine Razer-Mouse
anstöpselt,
dann installiert sich im Hintergrund, über Windows
Update, der Razer
Treiber.
So, der Razer Treiber
wird mit Systemrechten gestartet.
Das ist quasi noch mehr als Admin Rechte.
Leider
ist der Razer Treiber
ein bisschen unvorteilhaft,
oder der Installer für den Razer Treiber.
Warum es überhaupt einen Installer braucht,
weiß ich nicht, könnten die einfach
unattended machen. Leider ist der Installer
für den Razer Treiber
etwas unvorteilhaft
programmiert, und der
wird nicht etwa gestartet
dadurch, dass man
quasi ihn als User anklickt und dann
Admin werden muss, nein, dieser
Razer Treiber Installer wird
von Windows mit Systemrechten
gestartet. Das heißt, dadurch, dass
dieser Installer ein bisschen unvorteilhaft
programmiert ist, kann man direkt aus dem
Razer Treiber eine Admin Shell aufmachen
und hat die höchsten Systemrechte unter Windows.
Ich zeige euch das Ganze mal, finde ich ist eine äußerst
interessante Geschichte. Sound
braucht man nicht.
Ne, gibt's auch keinen Sound. Also
er zeigt jetzt erstmal, dass er kein Admin
auf der Kiste ist.
Geht nicht.
Übrigens, warum ist eigentlich Twitter Videos so
painstchemp? So,
als macht der Systemmanager auf oder
Device Manager geht auch nicht, weil er kein Admin
ist. So, und jetzt stöpselt er
seine Razer Maus an.
Razer Viper Ultimate.
So, man sieht schon,
kaum ist die Maus angestöpselt, läuft
im Hintergrund irgendwelche Treiber
Installer-Dinger los.
So. Und irgendwann
ploppt dann gleich der Razer Installer
auf. Bis jetzt so weit
alles kein Problem. Ja, das ist ja fast Standard,
dass Windows Update erstmal das halbe Internet
nachinstalliert.
So, alles, alles, alles Standard.
So, das Ding ist nur
ein bisschen doof programmiert. Guckt, der Windows Installer
läuft mit Systemrechten.
Und es ist nicht so, wie
wenn ich mir das jetzt aus dem Internet
runterlade und anklicke, dann
läuft das als mein User. Und
ich muss erstmal sagen, ich möchte jetzt zum Admin
wechseln. Und wenn ich keine Rechte für habe, darf ich das nicht.
Aber dieser Installer
hier
läuft mit Systemrechten. Das heißt,
der klickt jetzt den Installer durch,
klickt hier auf die Auswahl
für den Installationsort,
wo das installiert werden soll.
Jetzt geht ein Explorer auf mit Adminrechten.
Rechtsklick, PowerShell
Window, zack, AdminShell.
Windows, Alter.
Easy.
Das ist halt null
durchdacht, was sie da wieder getrieben haben.
Null durchdacht. Und das ist easy.
Und wisst ihr, was noch viel besser ist?
Wisst ihr, was noch viel besser ist?
Was daraus
ja, was daraus
wird, also sprich
was man daraus
machen kann.
Wir müssen euch jetzt vorstellen, man braucht ja gar keine
Razormaus. Es reicht ja
ein x-beliebig manipulierter,
ein x-beliebig manipulierbares
USB-Gerät, was sich als Razormaus
ausgibt. Solche programmierbaren
USB-Dongles gibt es ja für
1,50 Euro.
Kost ja nicht. Also kostet ja nicht
viel. So, und bei der Gelegenheit
kannst du sogar einen manipulierten USB-Stick
einstöpseln, der dann ganz
schnell irgendwas durchklickt oder so.
Mit Tastatur-Inputs.
Also das kannst du richtig
krass ausnutzen.
Du brauchst auch nicht mal ein offizielles Razor-Gerät
und das dann von Hand durchzuklicken oder so.
Ein Ricks-Lunch für den
Sub. So, das nächste ist, dass man damit
eventuell auch Remote-Desktops
exploiten kann.
Das müsste man mal ausprobieren. Es gibt ja die
Möglichkeit, dass man USB-Geräte mit
Remote-Desktops mitnimmt.
Und eventuell kann man
so sogar,
das müsste man aber erstmal ausprobieren,
kann man so sogar
Terminal-Server,
beispielsweise von irgendeinem Unternehmen,
Admin-Rechte drauf bekommen,
indem man ihnen sagt,
wenn sie das nicht deaktiviert haben,
dass man gerade über USB
eine Razormouse, über RDP
eine Razormouse forwardet.
Falls das geht.
Also das eröffnet auf jeden Fall
ziemlich viele,
es öffnet ziemlich viele Türen.
Und wenn man das
noch ein bisschen weiter verfeinert, ist das echt
ein hammer Ding, wo man überhaupt nicht dran gedacht hat.
Was ich auch lustig finde, ist,
er hat hier geschrieben
Tried contacting Razor, no answer.
Wundert mich nicht.
Also, ich hab erst einmal in meinem
Leben so ein, wie nennt man das?
Disclosure?
Ne, wie heißt denn das?
Wie nennt man das, wenn man
einen Hersteller anschreibt und sagt,
hey guck mal, ich hab da ne Sicherheitslücke gefunden.
Ich hab das jetzt irgendwie anlistet.
Ne, ne, ich hab keine NDA unterschrieben.
Ich hab das hier anlistet, hochgeladen
und, ja,
schickt mir mal ne Antwort oder ich veröffentlicht.
Ja, irgendwie sowas. Zumindest,
ich hab das erst einmal gemacht.
Ich habe es nie, doch, ich hab's veröffentlicht.
Ich hab's im Stream gezeigt ein paar Monate später.
Also das Einzige,
wo ich das mal gemacht habe, ist,
ich hab rausgefunden, dass man bei einer Kamera
von,
ich sag mal, ein Hersteller nicht,
ich hab mir ne Kamera gekauft auf Amazon,
halt so ne überall, ne Security-Kamera, Pan, Tilt,
Zoom, also eine, die man so drehen kann.
Und ich hab rausgefunden,
dass man dort mit einem ganz einfachen
Curl-Aufruf das Root-Passwort vom
Gerät rausbekommt. Und wenn man das
Root-Passwort vom Gerät hat, kann man natürlich jegliche
Kamera-Settings und Streams angucken,
ohne dass man die Rechte dafür hat.
Das war total easy.
Ich krieg's nicht mehr zusammen. Du musstest einfach nur
den Curl, genau, du musstest,
ich weiß es wieder, ich weiß
es wieder, wie das bei der Kamera
ging. Du musstest,
die Kamera hat eine
XML-Schnittstelle, wo Video-
Überwachungs-Software die verfügbaren
Streams discoveren kann. Also sprich,
dass man die Kamera nicht von Hand einrichten
muss, sondern mal einfach nur die IP, das irgendein
standardisiertes Protokoll. Für
Überwachungskameras geht natürlich noch über
XML, weil uralt.
Und da kann dich Software bei der Kamera
abfragen, sag mal, was für Feeds hast du denn?
So, und diese
Schnittstelle, wenn du da einen Curl hingeschickt
hast, so nach dem Motto, gib mir mal alle Feeds,
dann hat die Kamera nicht etwa geantwortet
mit, ja, das Video
findest du unter rtsp
www.camera-ip-slash-1,
sondern die Kamera hat geantwortet
mit, dass
den Feed findest du unter
rtsp
www.
root-doppelpunkt
add-camera-ip-slash-1. Also die hatten in der
url das root Passwort von der Kamera drin
stehen, wenn du den Stream
discovered hast über dieses Protokoll.
So, das habe ich denen geschickt, und da hat er
erst gesagt,
ja,
ich weiß gar nicht, aber er hat irgendwie geschrieben,
das Problem versteht er nicht,
ich soll mir doch mal die Hilfe-Seite auf
ihrer Webseite angucken.
Er hat gesagt, hallo,
das ist mir vollkommen wurscht,
ich kann mit einem Curl-Aufruf das
root Passwort von der Kamera rauskriegen, das kann
auch nicht gewollt sein. Und danach
hat er dann geantwortet, so nach dem Motto,
ah, okay, hat er falsch verstanden,
und ich soll mal bitte nichts sagen,
weil sie müssen das noch
patchen, und ob ich nicht bitte, ich habe
das unlisted auf GitHub hochgeladen,
so Proof of Concept, wie easy das ist,
und ob ich nicht
den GitHub-Eintrag
löschen könnte.
Ja, mache ich dann, wenn ich es
gefixt habe.
Und sie haben es tatsächlich nach einem
halben Jahr oder so,
ich habe irgendwie ein halbes Jahr später,
die Kamera war scheiße, die habe ich gar nicht im Einsatz,
ja.
Nach einem halben Jahr habe ich dann irgendwann
eine Mail bekommen, so nach dem Motto, das wurde jetzt
behoben. Das ist richtig,
richtig mies, richtig schlecht gelaufen.
So, und was ich hier witzig finde ist,
Razor hat geantwortet darauf.
Äh, Sekunde.
Ich muss mal kurz ein paar Vorschau
Videos zumachen,
das ist zu viel hier.
So. Und was ich lustig finde,
Razor hat darauf geantwortet, aber jetzt passt
mal auf wie.
Wo ist die Razor Antwort? Ich habe sie eben
noch gesehen. Haben die die gelöscht?
Wait a minute, hat Razor die Antwort
gelöscht? Warte mal.
Oder sehe ich die plus nicht?
Hat Razor die gelöscht?
Was macht denn Rezo wieder?
Also Razor hat geschrieben,
Razor hat geschrieben,
so nach, genau,
Black Ass GN.
Wo ist denn die Antwort von Razor? Bin ich jetzt
blöd?
Die haben die gelöscht, ne?
Ah ne, hier, hier ist sie.
Hier ist sie.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Razor hat darauf geantwortet, so richtig
Low Brain, Low IQ mäßig.
So nach dem Motto,
ah, du hast da Bedenken,
du hast da Bedenken. Und jetzt soll man
ihnen eine private Nachricht schicken
mit ihrer Ticketnummer, damit sie das
richtig eskalieren können. Also jetzt
mal ernsthaft. Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Das mag zwar,
bevor ich jetzt was Böses sage, aber
das mag zwar,
jetzt die Standard,
okay, ich muss jetzt mich ein bisschen
drüber aufregen. Das passiert.
Solche Antworten passieren nur,
wenn
irgendwelche Low IQ
Stonks BWL Leute
Prozesse definieren und
Leute sagen, zum Beispiel in ihrem
Support, du hast dich immer
dran zu halten,
sonst schmeißen wir dich raus, unsere Prozesse
sind unfehlbar
und du musst dich immer exakt an den
Prozess halten.
Weil jeder normal denkende Mensch und
auch der Razor Support
erkennt an dieser Stelle
eigentlich, dass man da handeln muss und
was man machen muss.
Der Razor Support
darf nicht anders antworten.
100 pro. Die haben garantiert eine
Anweisung, dass sie
immer ohne Ausnahme
so antworten müssen.
Das ist einfach ein typischer Fall
von Prozesse
über Gehirn.
Und das sollte nie sein, und wenn sich
irgendjemand mal ein bisschen ITIL Sachen und
sonstige Dinge durchgelesen hat, das steht da auch
immer drin, auch wenn das die ganzen ITIL
Vergötterer und Prozessleute nicht hören
wollen, das steht immer drin,
man muss gucken, was
zum jeweiligen Unternehmen passt
und man sollte das nicht
alles wortwörtlich nehmen, sondern nur als
Empfehlung. Das steht in so gut wie jedem
Prozess,
Agilität, sonstige Dinge drin.
Aber
es wird nicht gemacht. Du musst immer
sagen, ok, unsere Prozesse
sind dafür da, also müsstest du eigentlich sagen,
sind dafür da, uns in 90% der
Fällen eben einen Standard
Workflow zu ermöglichen. Aber
es kann nicht sein, dass wenn
sowas kommt, was hier eindeutig nicht
der Standard Support Fall Workflow ist,
sondern jemand, der wirklich ein sehr
wichtiges Problem
in schildert, dass man dort
jetzt eben nicht den Standard Workflow
abspulen muss. Das weiß der Razor Support.
Garantiert, die sind ja nicht doof beim Razor Support.
Die dürfen nicht anders drauf anfangen. Ich wette
mit euch, es gibt irgendeine Policy so nach
dem Motto, Support hat gefälligt
diese Eskalationsrichtlinien zu befolgen
und wenn sie das nicht machen, werden sie gekickt oder kriegen
eine Abmahnung. Und dementsprechend sagt der Razor
Support irgendwann, wisst ihr was,
leckt mich am Arsch, auch wenn ich persönlich
erkenne, dass es wichtig ist
und jetzt hier eigentlich anders reagiert werden soll,
ihr könnt mich mal, ich machs nach dem Prozess,
weil ihr das so darauf bestanden habt.
So, und das ist das, was passiert,
wenn Prozesse gewinnen über
Gehirn. Und das
geht nie gut aus.
So, und die Antwort ist natürlich
also wie gesagt, ich würde dem Razor Support
hier noch gar nicht mehr so großartig den Vorwurf machen,
weil sie wahrscheinlich wirklich exakt diese Anweisung
haben, so antworten zu müssen.
So, und das ist natürlich bescheuert.
Die Antwort ist an sich total beknackt,
weil, warum,
also erstens, er hat versucht Razor zu
kontaktieren, hat keiner geantwortet, jetzt hat er Razor
kontaktiert. Und jetzt so nach dem Motto,
als wären das seine Bedenken,
das sind die Bedenken, das sollten jetzt
Bedenken von Razor sein, hat auch einer
geantwortet. That be your concern now.
Genauso ist es.
Es ist nicht so etwa, dass er
ein Bedenken hat, dass man das ausnutzen kann,
das sind keine Bedenken. Er zeigt ihnen, dass das
ausnutzbar ist, dass man eine
Rutschel bekommt über den Razor Treiber.
Und
das jetzt von ihm noch zu verlangen,
dass sie quasi sich erbarmen,
diesen Problem anzunehmen,
nur wenn er eine DM schickt,
plus bei ihm noch eine Ticketnummer aufmacht,
ist einfach lächerlich.
Was Razor hat noch mehr verkackt,
XXL Thread.
Wo?
Boah, nein, das kann ich mir jetzt nicht.
Das legt mir jetzt alles durch.
Aber irgendjemand hat gerade Bilder gepaust.
Achso, hier, von dem, von dem gesamten.
What do I learn today?
Windows Docker
funktioniert nicht, wenn man den
Razor Synapse...
Ist Razor Synapse oder Synapse...
Ist das nicht die RGB-Steuerung von Razor?
Oder ist das der Treiber für alles?
Ok, also,
Docker und Windows funktionieren nicht, wenn man Razor Shit installiert hat.
Eigentlich müsste Razor...
Ja, ja, ja.
Genau, genau. Also das müsste Microsoft tatsächlich
machen. Microsoft müsste sagen,
wir liefern ab sofort
keinen Razor Treiber mehr über Windows Update
aus, erst, wenn
es eine halbwegs sichere
Installationsmethode gibt.
Also.
Achso, wenn man das Management Tool
laufen lässt. Ok. Also wenn man das
offen hat, das Management Tool für einen Razor Treiber,
kann man Docker nicht laufen lassen. Ok.
So, beide Programme wollen sicherstellen,
dass nur eine
von ihnen gleichzeitig läuft.
Oh fuck, wie
übersetzt man das jetzt?
Die erzeugen quasi
im
globalen Speicher so einen
Log,
so ein exklusives
Zugriffsteil mit
einer ID von ihrem
.NET Assembly. Also, würde man
erwarten, weil die
ID von einem.NET Assembly immer
unique ist.
Ok, sie machen es falsch.
Ok, warum machen sie es falsch?
Sie machen es beide falsch.
Docker für Windows und Razor
macht es falsch und sagt.
Global Object Get
Executing Assembly Get ID
Get Type. Ne, das funktioniert nicht.
Also, ich würde mal sagen,
das Get Type ist das Problem,
oder? Weil Get Type,
ne, Moment.
Get Type gibt doch immer das Gleiche zurück,
oder? Oder nicht?
Würde ich jetzt mal sagen.
Ah, Get Type. Ja.
Sag ich doch. Also, guck mal.
Ich hab diesen Code jetzt seit
einer Minute gesehen.
Und bin sicher nicht der krasseste Security-Hackster.
Und das erste, was mir aufgefallen ist,
dass Get Type irgendwie da nicht
passt. Warum fällt das
Big Brain Leuten von Docker und Razor
Highly Paid
Software Engineers nicht auf?
Monkastier, Alter.
So, was haben sie denn sonst noch?
Ja.
Genau.
Ist ja logisch. Beide Programme
registrieren sich quasi als Unic
mit der gleichen ID und dann
funktioniert das nicht.
Was? Der Gauferflow?
Moment. Die haben das von
der Gauferflow kopiert?
Das passiert, wenn man Sachen von
der Gauferflow kopiert.
Ja, sowohl Razor als auch
Docker für Windows
haben sich den Fehler von
Stack Overflow runterkopiert. Easy.
Highly Paid Professionals.
Richtig nice Hacker-Mans hier am Start.
Lustig.
Ja, kann schon mal passieren.
Kann schon mal passieren.
Dev Sack Ops. Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Dev Bis Sack
Full Stack Ops.
Also wir machen das
nicht mehr hier einfach nur mit eins
oder zwei Fachgebieten.
Dev Bis Sack
Full Stack Ops sind wir.
Übrigens Leute, wisst ihr was es heute für ein Video gibt?
Sekunde, Sekunde.
Muss ich mal kurz ausschalten. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob ich das
aufmachen kann ohne Leaks.
Hallo Leute.
Passt mal auf.
Was es heute für ein Video gibt.
Exquisite, Exquisite Video
gibt es heute.
Kleiner, kleiner, kleiner Teaser.
Hallo Leute, es wird mal wieder Zeit. Wir gucken uns
heute ein paar Stellenanzeigen zusammen an
und ich kann euch versprechen, es sind
wieder einige Highlights dabei. Und wenn euch
dieses Video gefällt oder wenn ihr mehr Videos dieser Art
sehen wollt, dann lasst mir an der Stelle auch jetzt
ein Abo da, dann sehen wir uns vielleicht in einem
der nächsten Videos dann wieder. Übrigens am Ende
des Videos blende ich euch
mal zwei, wie soll man es nennen,
Stellungnahmen, also Posts
von zwei Unternehmen ein.
Das gibt es nachher, wenn ich schon im Stream fertig bin. Ich habe es schon hochgeladen.
Und ich will das nicht
irgendwie verschweigen. Ich blende euch das am Ende
des Videos. Ich habe das schon hochgeladen.
Und kann es nachher freischalten, wenn das Stream
fertig ist.
Aber das war ja schon, da war ja eigentlich
von auszugehen. Gucken wir mal.
Vielleicht antwortet heute auch wieder einer drauf.
Und ich würde sagen, wir legen direkt los
und zwar mit einer Exquisite
Fivehead Anzeige
als Fullstack Developer
vom Land Hessen.
So, genug Teaser, dass ich euch
nachher noch auf YouTube angucke.
Nice wird wieder eine ganz alte
Abteilung gesucht in Person. Ja.
Unter anderem, unter anderem.
Dankeschön, Slim Beats, für den Sub.
Was ist noch übersehen?
So, gucken wir uns mal
ein paar Witz an.
08max07, danke schön
für den Prime Sub. Auch nicht gesehen.
Die hört gar nichts.
He lacks critical information.
Okay, also, was gucken wir uns heute an?
Also, die YouTube-Empfehlungen sind mal wieder
massive Threehead.
Es ist nur Müll dabei.
Wann kommt der zweite Hetzer?
Der zweite Hetzer-Stream?
Der zweite Hetzer-Stream
entweder heute Abend
oder morgen.
Hören euch ganz sicher.
Ich hab mir schon was ausgedacht, was wir machen.
Vielleicht sogar heute Abend.
Das letzte Rezo-Video?
Nein.
Das will ich mir nicht angucken.
Was hat er denn gemacht?
Ich muss mir nur den Titel...
Ach, schon wieder.
Zerstörung Teil 1.
Schon wieder.
Hat er den erst zerstört?
Dann kann Amthor jetzt wieder ankommen und sagen,
du alter Zerstörer.
Also, wie gesagt, Video-Empfehlungen
sind wieder...
Ich hab mir zum Glück noch ein paar andere Videos gefunden,
die man gucken kann.
Ansonsten,
nur irgendwelchen sinnlosen Crap,
den ich mir nicht angucken will.
Pass mal auf, Refresh wird nicht besser.
Es wird nicht besser.
Machen sie das?
Okay, ist vielleicht doch ganz interessant.
Ansonsten,
3G in allen Innenräumen.
Jetzt sind wir wieder bei dem Thema 3G.
Die meinen sicherlich nicht UMTS.
Doppeldeutige Abkürzungen sind einfach doof.
Also, ich weiß nicht,
was mit den YouTube-Empfehlungen los ist,
aber es ist auch gut,
weil es sehr gut ist.
Ah, hier guckt mal, für unsere Aiya-Yah-Fans.
Gibt's auch was zu gucken?
Moment, heißt diese Serie ernsthaft
I've been killing slimes
for 300 years and maxed out my level?
Ok, die Japaner drehen am Rad
Es ist, es ist nichts dabei, guck mal die Empfehlung, das ist so bitter. Ok, normalerweise kann man hier oben ja wenigstens jetzt noch welche
welche Gebiete man hat. Computer, Computer Hardware können wir sagen, Computer Hardware. Oder Electrical Engineering, Computer Hardware
Dann kriegen wir Linux 6 Tipps. Die müssen nicht zwangsläufig grün sein. Windows 11, da habe ich tatsächlich ein Video zu auf, einer der das glaube ich ganz gut zusammenfasst, zumindest den Bewertungen nach, aber das Wichtigste ist natürlich, dass eine WinRAR Lizenz abgelaufen ist, da muss man jetzt mal upgraden.
Jetzt übertreibt Aldi komplett. Gaming PC mit, Moment, Moment, das ist doch Werbung für Aldi, oder? Das ist doch, das ist doch PC Welt macht Werbung für Aldi. Anders kann ich mir das nicht vorstellen hier.
Oder auch nicht. Wie viel kostet der?
Ja, 3200 Euro. Alter, jetzt aber mal gut.
Übertreibt es halt, ja.
Bei Otto. Deutsche Otto-Lan. Alter, was kostet denn bei Aldi?
Alter, fuck, meine Güte, was ist denn mit euch los? Ich meine RTX 3090 alleine kostet ja schon immer ein Drittel davon.
Aber trotzdem, das ist fucking teuer. Was ist denn da drinnen?
Für das Geld kann man sich schon ein Auto kaufen. Also wenn ihr den, pass auf, Pro-Tipp, was ich mir jetzt habe sagen lassen vom Kollege auf der Arbeit, der sich ein Auto gekauft hat, wenn ihr ein besonders günstiges Auto haben wollt, dann müsst ihr euch aktuell ein Diesel-Auto kaufen, die keiner mehr haben will.
Ihr habt damit dann zwar Probleme, dass ihr in Zukunft nirgendswo mehr hinfahren dürft oder extra Steuern bezahlen müsst oder was auch immer machen müsst, aber es ist in den Anschaffungskosten wohl billig.
Alter, ist das teuer. Opel Agila ist allein schon der Name, sagt ja.
Also, alle Infos, ich muss jetzt gucken, was da drinnen ist. Alter, ich habe wieder was im Hals.
So, was die Telekom hatte, eine Data-Preach, das kenne ich noch gar nicht. Können wir uns gleich durchlegen.
Also, was ist denn da drinnen? Okay, ich glaube, der ist auch ganz gut. Warum macht man da nicht ein Ryzen-System? Ich glaube, da würde man aktuell, wobei, ich glaube, die Dinge sind einfach gut lieferbar, oder, die Intel-CPUs?
Ich glaube, wir wissen das aktuell, sind Intel-CPUs besser lieferbar als AMD, weil AMD alle haben wollen und Intel keiner zurzeit, oder wie ist das? Ich verfolge das nicht, ich verfolge das immer nur dann, wenn ich mir einen Rechner kaufen will.
Alle gut lieferbar.
Gut, ich muss sagen, das Setup sieht tatsächlich okay aus. 32 GB RAM, 2 TB SSD. Also, ich glaube, das Setup an sich ist gar nicht so verkehrt und ich würde jetzt einfach mal aus dem Bauch raus vermuten, dass der Preis, wenn ich es mir so zusammen stelle, gar nicht mal so ein Ryzen-Unternehmen.
Der Unterschied ist, was sagen Sie denn Fazit? Der RAM ist ein bisschen langsam, was ist das denn für ein 3200? Ist doch in Ordnung. Und was sagen Sie Fazit?
Ja, gut, der Preis der Einzelkomponenten 264 Euro. Ja, das ist aber doch durchaus vertretbar. Dafür bekommst du ihn da zusammengebaut und komplett.
Ja, warum es da noch eine 2 TB HDD gibt, verstehe ich nicht. Also, wenn schon, kann man die weglassen oder macht da was ordentliches rein.
Wenn schon, macht man da was ordentliches rein. Irgendwie 6 oder 8T HDD, wenn überhaupt, dass sich das ganze lohnt. Früher war es so, da waren die Aldi-PCs, also zu Zeiten, wo ich tatsächlich noch geguckt habe nach Aldi-PC-Angeboten, also so, was weiß ich, 97, 98, 99, 2000 rum oder so, da waren die Aldi-Angebote teilweise der richtige Killer.
Also, die waren teilweise ein Drittel billiger, als wenn du dir den Scheiß so gekauft hättest. Das war wirklich brutal günstig, auch im Medienmarkt auch teilweise. Wobei die damals genauso getrickst haben wie heute, teilweise mit irgendwelchen komischen OEM Boards, die du so retail nie bekommen würdest und abgespeckt sind an Stellen, die es günstiger machen, aber man auf den ersten Blick nicht sieht.
So was weiß ich, Frontside-Buzz langsamer war ja damals noch ein Ding, interessiert ja heute keinen mehr, Frontside-Buzz langsamer, dann Grafikkarten irgendwie einfach nur mit halbem RAM, wobei da hat Nvidia Erfahrung bei der, war das bei der 70, 970, bei welcher Grafikkarte war das, wo Nvidia das letzte Gigabyte oder das letzte halbe Gigabyte, 79, etwas schwachbrustig angebunden hat.
Was haben die für einen Netzteil?
Seasonic, Focus, ist das das Gehäuse oder das Netzteil?
Das Netzteil, ja.
Das ist aber nicht schlecht, also Seasonic macht echt gute Netzteile.
Also ich hatte die letzten Jahre über zwei verschiedene, also nicht nur zwei verschiedene Netzteile, aber zwei verschiedene Hersteller. Ich hatte entweder Be Quiet oder Seasonic, aber Seasonic Focus hatte ich noch nie, das scheint ja die Billig-Reihe von ihnen zu sein, aber es ist immer noch nix versus LG Power.
Hatte mal jemand, hatte mal jemand das Vergnügen mit einem LC Power oder LG Power? LC Power heißen die glaube ich.
China-Netzteil.
LC Power.
Die Dinger.
Monka Smoke ist da angesagt, ich sag's euch.
Alarm, Alarm.
Die will man nicht, die will man nicht.
Also das ist das einzige Netzteil, wo mir wirklich mal eins verreckt ist von.
Ich muss sagen, ich hatte bisher immer ziemlich viel, ziemlich viel Glück, was Hardware angeht.
Also mir ist, mir ist, also mir ist mal ein CRT abgeraucht, so wirklich mit, mit Smoke, aber ihr könnt euch vorstellen, als wenn es ein CRT war, das war glaube ich ein 21 Zoll Samsung CRT.
Also sowas, was du, wo du erstmal Gewicht heben musst vorher, dass du das überhaupt transportieren kannst, dass du erstmal ein halbes Jahr Gewicht heben musst vorher, dass du ein Monitor transportieren kannst.
Mit 21 Zoll CRT ist mir mal abgeraucht von Samsung und ein LC Power-Netzteil.
Aber ansonsten war ich immer selbst dran schuld, ja.
Also zum Beispiel Microcontroller, falschen Spannungswandler oder irgendwas.
Aber, ne wobei, außer im Stream bei dem China-Spannungswandler, da konnte ich an nichts für.
Die drei Sachen, der China-Spannungswandler im Stream, LC Power-Netzteil und mein 21 Zoll CRT damals.
Ansonsten ist mir, glaube ich noch nie wirklich, was abgeraucht.
Mir sind schon ein paar Magnetfestplatten kaputt gegangen.
Was hat das damals gekostet, das CRT?
Puh, weiß ich nicht.
Ich hab das, ich, ich, ich glaube ich hab das auch nicht gekauft.
Ich hab das bekommen, weil sie das in irgendeinem Büro ausgemustert haben.
Der war aber ziemlich gut.
Das war ein 21 Zoll oder, oder, oder hatte man damals nicht so, 20 Zoll war das, glaube ich.
Oder 21 Zoll, so die, die 4 zu 3, die 4 zu 3 Geschichte.
Und, ach so ja, Smoke im Stream, ich zeig's euch mal, weil's gerade im Chat gepostet wurde, genau.
Ähm, ne, ne, es war kein 19 Zoll, es war größer als 19 Zoll.
19 Zoll hatte ich davor.
Ich hatte, ich hatte, am Anfang hab ich mit 14, 15 Zoll angefangen.
Danach hatte ich einen, einen 19 Zoll und dann hatte ich dieses 21 Zoll CRT.
Und das war relativ gut, warte mal.
21 Inch.
Monitor.
Sowas hier, genau.
So, so oder so ähnlich sah das Ding aus.
Sowas hier.
Ja, was wiegt sowas?
Wir gucken mal doch mal, was sowas wiegt.
2000 rum, ja, kommt doch hin.
Gewicht.
Zum Glück.
Kilogramm gibt's nicht.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie ne Mikrowelle, ja.
Bei den Amis kannst du nicht gucken, da ist das Gewicht in ounces oder sowas.
LBS, alter.
Was zum Teufel ist LBS?
Uh, Kilogramm, bitteschön.
So, 26 Kilogramm.
Und das war noch, man muss sagen, der ist relativ, der ist relativ klein auch noch.
Das ging noch, die ginge noch deutlich schwerer als 26 Kilogramm.
Guck mal, da ist noch relativ klein, es gab welche, die waren viel fetter.
Das geht noch, 26 Kilo.
Ami-Einheiten sind nicht 5-Hat, die Ami-Einheiten sind 3-Hat.
Junge, was ist da drin?
Naja, ein CRT halt.
Oder auf Deutsch eine Kathodenstrahlröhre.
Heißt das doch auf Deutsch, oder?
Nein, nicht Critical Race Theorie.
Kathodenstrahlröhre, ja.
Klar.
Naja, das ist schwer, so sieht das von innen aus.
Du hast komplett erstmal Glas vorne.
Glas mit irgendeiner Phosphorschicht drauf.
So, dann hast du hinten ganz viel Metall.
Und das hier ist ja das eigentliche Ding, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist ja das eigentliche Ding, was aus sehr hoher Spannung irgendwelche, frag mich nicht, Elektronen, Photonen, Strahlen vorne drauf ballert.
Und ja, dann leuchtet die Schicht ganz kurz vorne.
Rage Resistence, ja, den hast du damals nicht so einfach kaputt gemacht.
Den musst du immer auch degausen.
Hat jemand mal von euch so Boomer Talk, hat einer mal sein Monitor degaust?
Ich hab das damals schon gemacht.
Degaust, Alter.
Da hat das Bild immer so gewackelt.
Das war, falls dein Monitor irgendwelche magnetischen Einstrahlung abgekriegt hat, dann konntest du den irgendwie entmagnetisieren oder sowas.
Degaust, ja.
Ah, guck mal hier, hier.
Hier gibt es sogar ein Video dazu.
Degaust mich.
Bäm, so sah das aus.
Da wird die Gaust.
Bäm.
Ja, das sind Zeiten, da hab ich angefangen mit Computer-Stalls, sowas angesagt.
Ja, der ist mir abgeraucht.
Und ich hab damals was richtig Dummes gemacht mit meinem Monitor.
Wie gesagt hier, Sync Master 110P.
Ich hab damals was richtig Hängen gebliebenes gemacht, was ich heute nie wieder gemacht hätte.
Hatte der Monitor gerade 100 Hertz, ja, das kann schon sein.
100 Hertz war damals sogar relativ verbreitet.
Also über 100 Hertz, man konnte, zu CRT-Zeiten war das Coole, man konnte Monitore übertakken.
Jaja, aber 100 Hertz war damals bei höherpreisigen Modellen relativ normal, gerade bei niedrigeren Auflösungen.
Da ist ja die Wiederholfrequenz mit der Auflösung skaliert.
Also sprich, du konntest dann 800 x 600 mit, keine Ahnung, 120 Hertz, aber irgendwie 1600 x 1200 dann nur mit 80 oder 85 oder so.
Zumindest...
Nee, nee, das erzähl ich jetzt nicht mit dem Typ im Store.
Zumindest, ich hab was richtig bescheuertes gemacht.
Das Ding ist abgeraucht, ich hab mir gedacht, fuck, woran liegt das?
Ich hab das Ding genommen, also so, hab den Monitor hier genommen, hab ihn ins Wohnzimmer getragen, weil da Platz war.
Und hab ihn auseinandergebaut, weil ich irgendwie gedacht hab, ja, so mein, keine Ahnung, 15-jähriges Selbst oder so.
Wie alt war ich? 98, 99 rum, 99 war ich, ich bin 480,15.
Ja, ich hab mit 15 gedacht, ich kann das Ding aufmachen und irgendwie fixen, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Das Problem ist, ich hätte da instant sterben können eigentlich.
Also ich hab das, ich hab das, ich hab das abgestöpselt, bin ins Wohnzimmer, hab das aufgeschraubt und hab da drinnen rumgefingert mit meinen Fingern.
Also ich hab das aufgebaut, aufgemacht, dass es so aussah innen drinnen.
Also ich hab Glück, dass ich nicht instant gestorben bin dabei.
Also macht so Zeug nicht, ja.
Nicht aufschrauben.
Gerade die Dinger, die was weiß ich, 50 Billiarden Volt Spannung intern verwenden, ist keine so gute Idee da dran zu greifen.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Gut, genug Boomer-Stories würde ich sagen.
Wir gucken uns jetzt erstmal ein paar Sachen an.
So.
Die Tür bei der Mikrowelle ist bloat.
So hab ich das noch nie gesehen.
Solange nicht Java auf der Mikrowelle läuft, ist alles in Ordnung.
Ja, übrigens noch mal zur Vollständigkeit halber.
So sieht's aus.
Als ich meinen China-Chinesen-Spannungswandler, ne, wobei das stimmt ja nicht.
Der China-Chinesen-Spannungswandler ist abgekackt und daraufhin ist der Controller abgekackt.
Guck mal, wie ordentlich ich das hier gemacht hab.
Sogar schön rechteckig und sowas.
Das mach ich normalerweise nie.
Und dann fackelts auch noch ab.
Ja, ich hab das auch noch nie gesehen.
Sogar schön rechteckig und sowas. Das mach ich normalerweise nie. Und dann fackelts auch noch ab.
Pass mal auf so.
Es hat geplinkt. Das plinkt ganz kurz. Okay. Habt ihr's gesehen? Ich hab eben nicht hingeguckt. Guck mal.
Wow, wow.
Smoke.
Rum.
Habt ihr's gesehen hier?
Wow, wow, wow.
Ja.
Warum?
So. Ich weiß übrigens bis heute nicht, warum das Ding abgeraucht ist.
Einfach nur, also es ist ja nichts verkehrt angeschlossen gewesen.
Das ist einfach nur billiger China-Chinesen-China-Spannungswandler gewesen.
So. Und das Schlimme ist, das Schlimme ist, danach, das ist nicht nur der Spannungswandler abgeraucht.
Und jetzt kommt ja, der Spannungswandler ist so richtiges Low-End, Low-IQ-China-Produkt.
Denn nicht nur der Spannungswandler, ich hab nicht plus und minus vertauscht. Wie soll denn das gehen? Davor lief's doch.
Ich hab einfach nur Stecker rein rausgezogen.
So. Und das Problem war, der Spannungswandler ist nicht einfach verreckt.
Nein, der Spannungswandler war dann der Meinung, er macht einfach Input zu Output. Was auch immer.
Also sprich, normalerweise war das ein Spannungswandler, 12 Volt auf 5 Volt.
Und nachdem der Spannungswandler abgeraucht ist, hat der Spannungswandler gewandelt von 12 Volt auf 12 Volt.
12 Volt. Also ich hab dann damit auch noch einen 25 Euro Microcontroller gekillt.
Weil der verkraftet halt keine 12 Volt als Input.
Billiges China-Crap-Zeugs da, ey.
Naja. Gut, jetzt hätten wir das geklärt.
Ich muss euch noch was auf Twitter zeigen. Sekunden, Leute, es muss jetzt einfach noch sein.
Der Chat muss nicht abgucken.
Ich will sehen, ob ihr high oder low IQs seid, weil mein Chat müsste ja eigentlich massive brains sein, durch die ganzen Prime-Subs.
Also Chat. Chat, was kommt raus? Rechne das mal aus. Kein Taschenrechner benutzen, rechne das mal aus im Kopf.
Massive Fivehead.
So schnell habt ihr im Leben nicht gerechnet, ihr habt das einfach copy-pasted, weil ihr's wisst.
Copy-pasted, weil ihr's wisst. Okay.
Also 104 ist richtig. 104 ist richtig. Ihr seid aber in guter Gesellschaft für alle, die es falsch gemacht haben.
Also die Hälfte der Amis konnte es nicht richtig rechnen.
Und am besten sind die Antworten, wo irgendwelche Leute schreiben, der Taschenrechner ist falsch oder ich bin Mathelehrer und das Ergebnis ist vier.
Oder warum sollte man denn mal null rechnen, das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn und sonst was.
Und ich hab gestern mal meine Mutter gefragt, hab ich gesagt, hier, Mama, guck mal, was sagst du dazu? Was kommt da raus?
Und meine Mutter hatte irgendwie, was weiß ich, 76 oder irgendwie sowas, keine Ahnung, wie sie darauf gekommen ist, irgendwas mit Pan 70.
Hab ich gesagt, okay, falsch. Warum? Ja hast du schon mal was von Punkt vor Strich-Rechnung gehört?
Hat sie gesagt, äh, also in Mathe war ich noch nie gut.
Also in Mathe war ich noch nie gut. Und da hab ich mir gedacht, okay, ich bin einfach wieder mal von den vollkommen falschen Annahmen ausgegangen.
Ich dachte eigentlich, dass quasi nahezu 100% der Menschheit weiß, dass man so als Convention Punkt vor Strich-Rechnung macht.
Ich mein, mal ganz streng genommen ist es übrigens korrekt, dass, was manche in den Kommentaren geschrieben haben, es fehlt da irgendwie eine Info dazu.
Also man könnte, aber ganz ehrlich, Punkt vor Strich-Rechnung ist einfach so eine Sache, die sich etabliert hat.
Und viele Sachen stimmen einfach schlicht und ergreifend nicht, wenn man ohne Punkt vor Strich-Rechnung rechnet.
Du machst ja normalerweise in der Reihenfolge Klammern immer zuerst.
Also wenn man wirklich was komplett Missverständ und unmissverständlich machen will, dann musst du es eigentlich klammern.
Dann müsstest du das hier eigentlich klammern.
So, aber der Einfachheit halber hat man sich drauf geeinigt, wie sowas hier zu interpretieren ist.
Wenn man keinen Interpretationsspielraum lassen will, dann muss man es klammern.
Äh, normalerweise machst du Klammern zuerst.
Dann machst du Wurzeln und Exponent. Ich hoffe, ich erzähle jetzt keinen Witz.
Äh, kein Mist, Alter.
Äh, du machst Klammern immer zuerst.
Dann machst du Wurzeln und Exponent.
Dann machst du Punkt vor Strich.
Und dann machst du, tja, plus, minus.
Und wenn du gleichwertige Sachen hast, dann von links nach rechts.
So, aber nachdem sich quasi die ganze Welt darauf geeinigt hat, dass man Punkt vor Strich Rechnung macht, ist die richtige Antwort 104.
Unabhängig von irgendwelchen Klammern.
Äh, da rechnest du das hier zuerst. Das ist 0.
Dann machst du 50 plus 50 ist 100 minus 0.
Ist immer noch 100 plus 2 plus 2 ist 104.
Wie viel ist x in der Aufgabe? Ja, das ist ein bisschen unglücklich gestellt.
Weil x ist eigentlich die Grundschulvariante von mal.
Aber gut, da kannst du nichts machen.
Der wollte es halt besonders eindeutig machen, dass es jeder versteht.
Wobei auch hier, das dummes Zeichen für es, eigentlich, eigentlich ist geteilt das hier.
Wenn man mal ehrlich ist.
Und noch besser schreibt man geteilt eigentlich eh als Bruch.
Also guckt euch mal, guckt euch mal irgendwelche Formel an, da ist das eigentlich meistens als Bruch geschrieben.
Hätte nicht erwartet, dass sowas mal Thema hier im Stream wird. Ja, das muss ich einfach zeigen. Das ist einfach zu low-brain, die Leute.
Am besten finde ich den Typ übrigens, der gesagt hat, mal 0, ähm, geht nicht.
Oder mal, wie hat er geschrieben, mal 0 ergeht nicht.
Wenn er 75, achja, die beste Antwort, die beste Antwort war immer noch, 75 mal 0 ist 75.
Aber das ist halt, das ist halt hell yeah. Freedom Kokona, ja.
75 mal 0 ist 75. Und die Erklärung, ich muss mal gucken, 75 mal 0 ist 75.
Und die Erklärung, ich muss mal gucken, Ich muss gucken, ob ich das hier finde.
Wo ist der, wo ist der 75? Moment, ich hab doch, ich hab doch auf Twitter, ich hab doch, ich hab doch gepostet.
Ich hab doch die Antwort gepostet auf Twitter.
Das ist der beste, das ist wirklich, das ist typisch, typisch, don't cry so much, danke
für den Sub, das ist typisch Kekona.
Ähm, hier, hier, ja, was, also wenn man 75
Dollar mit 0 multipliziert, dann hast du immer noch 75 Dollar, nein, das wäre mit 1, weil
du hast ja 1 mal 75 Dollar, also du machst einen Haufen aus 75 1 Dollar Schein oder was
auch immer, ja, dann hast du 75 mal 1 Dollar oder meinetwegen nimmst du, meinetwegen nimmst
du den Haufen als 1 und sagst, das sind 75 Dollar, aber es ist ein Haufen, es ist ein
Haufen, ja, ein leerer Tisch, ein leerer Tisch sind 75 Dollar mal 0, du hast eine nicht existenten
Stapel 75 Dollar, wobei man sagen muss 0 ist tatsächlich so ein Konzept, das gibt's
noch nicht, ich sag jetzt mal so lang, äh, die Griechen und äh, quasi andere frühzeitliche
Mathe Big Brains, die hatten sowas noch nicht, es ist ja auch erstmal nicht sonderlich intuitiv
mit 0, ja, das ist erst so aufgekommen, als man sich so theoretisch mehr mit der ganzen
Sache beschäftigt hat, weniger, bisschen weg von rein praktischen Anwendungen, ich meine
die Griechen, die haben eh alles geometrisch irgendwie gebastelt, also die Griechen die
hatten im Prinzip nur, nur Kreise und Ecken, was die Griechen nicht als Kreise und Ecken
malen konnten, gab's nicht und dafür, dafür muss man, muss man ihnen mal, muss man ihnen
mal zu gut halten, haben die ziemlich viel rausbekommen, dafür, dass die eigentlich
nur, in Anführungsstrichen, zum größten Teil Geometrie gemacht haben, so, was kannst
du das im Stream vorrechnen, 8 durch, äh, du rechnest die Klammern zuerst, also, also,
theoretisch dürfte, theoretisch dürfte das eigentlich relativ einfach sein, äh, achso,
das geht nicht, das geht nicht, warte mal, oder, geht das doch, doch klar geht das, 2
plus 2 ist 4, 2 mal, 2 mal 2, äh, 2 mal 4 ist 8, 8, äh, 8 durch 8, 0, äh 1, 0, oder?
Wieso multiplizieren, weil hier, weil hier ein Mal dazwischen steht, weil, weil das hier
ein Mal ist dazwischen, also das hier, das hier bedeutet ja eigentlich, das hier bedeutet
ja eigentlich, ähm, mal, da steht ja eigentlich auch ein Mal dazwischen, ich mein, das war
schon der richtige 3, im Moment, als ich grad gesagt hab, 8 durch 8 ist 0, aber, als Stattz1,
wie kommt man auf 16, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie kommt man denn auf 16, wie, wie kommt
man auf 16, äh, ich weiß nicht wie man auf 16 kommt, wie kommt man auf 16, wobei, warte
mal, Moment, Moment, Moment, das ist, das ist tatsächlich richtig, äh, ich, ich glaube
sogar 16, ich warte mal, 16 könnte sogar richtig sein, ich glaube ich bin da zu, ich bin da,
bin da zu low IQ gewesen, das stimmte klar, guck dir mal, das ist, das musst du von links
nach rechts machen, du rechnest das mal aus, das ist 4, so, ähm, und dann müsstest du
eigentlich von links nach rechts rechnen, was dann, was dann das hier, was dann quasi
4 wären, und dann würdest du 4 mal 4 rechnen, das sind 16, oder hab ich's am Anfang richtig
gemacht, das ist tatsächlich, ist denn, tja, das ist eine gute Frage, das ist, gar nicht
so, gar nicht so ohne, viral math problem, was sagt denn, was sagt denn der Taschenrechner
dazu, äh, wo ist denn, wo ist denn die ursprüngliche, wir fragen mal Google, Google weiß das, Google
sagt 16, ja, Google, Google hat recht, na gut, Programmiersprache deiner Wahl ist nicht
unbedingt so gut, die haben manchmal etwas abweichende Bindungen, was Operator angeht.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, also, ähm, so aus dem Bauch aus hätte ich erst mal eins gerechnet,
klar, weil ich irgendwie hier auf der rechten Seite am Start war mit Auflöser, aber normalerweise
musst du ja, also, wenn du gleichwertige Operation hast, musst du dann von links nach rechts
machen, also, ich würde fast sagen, ist, aha, korrekt Antwort heute ist 16, siehste, ja,
also, chat, wir können uns darauf einigen, wir hatten alle recht, Heißens sagt 4, na,
das wäre nicht jetzt aber merkwürdig, wenn das, also, auf 4 kommt man da wahrscheinlich
relativ, na, Windows Kalk, es sagt ja auch, wenn Google 16 sagt, na, hat Google recht,
ganz einfach, bloß, danke für den Sub, wir sind uns ja einig, dass Google bei sowas
prinzipiell recht hat, wie immer, also, es gibt zwei Instanzen auf dieser Welt, die immer
recht haben, das ist Google und der Twitch-Chat, und sollten sich mal Google und der Twitch-Chat
widersprechen, implodiert das komplette Universum, aber das kommt ja glücklicherweise nie vor,
das ist der Google Calculator in Go, tja, keine Ahnung, Funktionale Programme in Go,
das ist nicht, Leute, wir gucken jetzt mal Videos, wir haben mal Zeit hier, genug, also,
Leute, ich glaube, ihr müsst mir zustimmen, wir haben heute genug für unseren High IQ
getan im Stream, oder, jetzt können wir uns irgendwie ein bisschen Low-Prain-Sachen angucken,
also, IQ bildende Maßnahmen haben wir heute durch, so, all die, so, dann hatten wir noch
irgendwie Security-Preach bei der Telekom, bitte nichts politisches, nee, hatte ich nicht
vor, das geht mir eh gerade alles auf den Sack, ich versuche, mich da so wenig wie möglich
damit zu beschäftigen, und ich hoffe, die Leute lassen mich in Ruhe mit ihrem Crap, so,
wobei wir das, eins, machen wir das nächste Mal, nächstes Wochenende, glaube ich, ist
es, nee, übernächstes Wochenende machen wir aber wieder den Wahl-O-Mat, da bin ich mal
gespannt, ob wieder rauskommt, dass ich die Partei wählen soll, wobei die Partei gibt's
bei der Bundestagswahl gar nicht, oder, gibt's die Partei, kam das letzte Mal bei mir raus,
letztes Mal kam raus, glaube ich, 85% die Partei, gefolgt, ich glaube sogar von der
AfD, und FDP, ich glaube ganz, ganz unten waren bei mir, ähm, waren bei mir ganz unten,
ich glaube die SPD oder so, egal, ähm, Mordteam zittert schon, mal gucken, was diesmal der
Wahl-O-Mat ausspuckt, ich interpretiere, glaube ich, aber beim Wahl-O-Mat auch immer
ein bisschen zu viel rein, nee, nee, das machen wir jetzt nicht, das machen wir jetzt nicht,
wir machen jetzt keinen Wahl-Swiper, vielleicht, vielleicht am Ende, vielleicht am Ende des
Streams, muss ich mal gucken, also, also, was hat die Telekom, Security Preach, keep you
safe from Cyber Security Threats, Moment, sie protekten mich, indem sie meine Daten verlieren
oder wie, wirst du die Battlefield Beta Stream, ja, sobald das rauskommt, what happened, ok,
also, also, was, was hat die Telekom, T-Mobile, gut, das ist wahrscheinlich bei den Amis oder,
also irgendein Bad Actor, was ist immer das so, diese, diese offizielle, dieses offizielle
drumherum gelabere, also irgendein Typ hat sich illegal Zugang zu persönlichen Daten
beschafft, so, sie untersuchen das weiterhin, ok, T-Mobile, es wurde auf T-Mobile Daten zugegriffen
von nicht autorisierten Leuten und es wurden Daten geklaut, übrigens, man kann, übrigens,
ich finde, ich finde das immer so, so, Data Stolen oder auch Datendiebstahl und so, ich
finde, das ist immer, das ist so doof bezeichnet, eigentlich kannst du ja Daten nicht wirklich
stehlen in dem Sinn, du kannst dir das kopieren, also, Datendiebstahl klingt immer so, als
ist es dann an der Quelle irgendwie weg, gut, es gibt sicherlich welche, die kopieren sich
und löschen es danach, also, Steuerung X wäre dann quasi Diebstahl, wobei es ja immer
noch einen Backup gibt oder sonst was, also, Datendiebstahl finde ich das Wort an sich
echt unglücklich, man müsste, man müsste dafür eigentlich einen komplett neuen Begriff
erfinden, der auch thematisch irgendwie besser passt, so, Person Information haben sie geklaut,
so, was haben sie denn, was wurde denn geklaut, Hallo, Details are available here, nein, ah,
hier doch, aber das ist doch das, was wir gerade gelesen haben, Alter, ist ja gut, ist
ja gut, Telekom, die wollen es aber wissen, ok, also, die haben irgendwelche Daten abgezogen,
Personal Things, also, was haben wir denn hier, Namen, Hörerschein, ja, Passnummer, Social
Security Name, das ist irgendwie so ein Ami Ding, das ist irgendwelche Sachen auf den Personalausweis,
Geburtsdatum, T-Mobile Prepaid Pins, ok, Adressentelle, ok, also, man könnte sagen,
man könnte sagen, mehr oder weniger alles, ok, Payment Informationen und Kontogeschichten
nicht, auch keine Kredite, na gut, es reicht mir ja ehrlich gesagt schon, wenn meine kompletten
persönlichen Daten jetzt im Umlauf sind, damit kannst du ja genug anstellen, we are
relentlessly focused on taking care of our customers, natürlich, natürlich, das ist
so, wie wenn Blizzard sagt, das wird jetzt alles gut, so nach dem Motto, ja, ganz bestimmt,
wurde mal wieder was geleakt, ja, das habe ich auch gerade zum ersten Mal erfahren, as
we move quickly to protect you, das ist so ein Bullshit Gelaber immer, wie wollen die
mich protecten, wenn jemand bei ihnen meine persönlichen Daten geklaut hat, was genau,
also was liegt noch in der Macht der Telekom, mich dann da zu protecten, man die können
meine Prepaid Pins resetten oder sowas, aber wenn jetzt irgendjemand mit meinem geklauten
Führerschein oder Passnummer oder Geburtsdatum sich irgendwo anmeldet und Drogen bestellt
oder was weiß ich, ja, dann, wie, wie will mich die Telekom davor protecten, du kannst,
du kannst dich umbenennen lassen, genau, du lässt dich einfach umbenennen, neuen Ausweis
machen, easy, ich heiße ab jetzt Peter, wie da, wie von Microsoft Support, ich nenne mich
um, Vorname Peter, Nachname von Microsoft Support, Activate Scamshield, ja na klar, na
klar, das ist auch so eine geile, geile Taktik, guck mal, die Telekom verliert deine Daten,
die Telekom verliert deine Daten und jetzt wollen sie dir noch McAfee, Protection und
Scamshield verkaufen, das ist auch eine geile Taktik, so, 40 Millionen Kundensätze bei
T-Mobile hack gestohlen, schreibt dir die Fats dazu, einmal Reganischen Mobilfunk, Tochter
der Telekom, ja, T-Mobile gibt es ja bei uns nämlich also wirklich und tritt kaum noch
in Erscheinung, das fand ich übrigens interessant, dass, was man, bei der Fußball-WM, ne, und
auch bei, bei Olympischen Spielen, aber gerade bei der Fußball-WM, früher hattest du bei
der Fußball-WM als Werbung irgendwie Kronbacher oder irgendwelche Bierdinger oder Autos und
heute hattest du T-Mobile, TikTok, Instagram, Zeug, sieht man, hat man sich auch gedacht,
gut, so ändern sich die Zeiten, 100 Millionen User ergattert, ja, GDL-Streik finde auf dem
Rücken der Kunden schon, ist ja auch so, jeglicher Streik im Nahverkehr findet immer auf dem
Rücken der Kunden statt, wie soll das auch anders sein, das heißt nicht, dass sie nicht
streiken dürfen, da bin ich ja auch voll dabei, Alipay, ja, ich hab tatsächlich Alipay
schon mal verwendet vor einiger Zeit, als man nur noch damit bei Aliexpress bestellen
konnte, übrigens, ab nächster Woche gibt es wieder Bahnstreiks und ja, natürlich ist
das auf dem Rücken der Kunden, die dürfen streiken, aber ganz ehrlich, es fuckt mich
trotzdem ab und die sollen einfach ihre Leute, die sollen einfach ihre Leute ordentlich bezahlen,
ja, guck mal, hier Bahnstreik, ist ab nächster Woche wieder, ach nee, Bahn kommt GDL entgegen,
vielleicht, vielleicht, vielleicht ist es doch, das ist ja eine Corona Prämie, ach
so, für die Lokführer, jeder vierte Fernzug soll rollen, das ist ganz schön wenig, jeder
vierte Fernzug, das ist 25%, also das heißt 75% der Züge fallen aus, natürlich hört
es sich besser an, wenn man sagt, jeder vierte Fernzug soll rollen, als wenn man sagt 75%
fällt aus, ganz ehrlich, die Bahn müsste dich einfach kostenlos fahren lassen in der
Zeit, ja, also, wie gesagt, die GDL und so, die dürfen meinetwegen gerne streiken, ich
habe nichts dagegen, dass die GDL streikt, aber man darf sich das nicht schönreden,
selbstverständlich ist es auf dem Rücken der Bahnkunden ausgetragen und ich muss mich
da auch nicht irgendwie solidarisch mit zeigen, wie das die Leute auf Twitter schreiben, so
nach dem Motto, GDL, ich stehe hinter euch, nein, in Scheiß stehe ich, ich stehe nicht
hinter der Bahn, ich stehe nicht hinter der GDL, ich stehe, wenn es um öffentlichen Nahverkehr
geht, genau hinter einem und das bin ich selbst, ich will pünktlich von A nach B gebracht
werden, die Umstände dazwischen sind mir absolut scheißegal, ich will einfach nur, dass das
funktioniert, es ist egal, ob die GDL Scheiße baut, ob die Bahn Scheiße baut oder sonst
irgendwer, ich will mich überhaupt nicht damit beschäftigen, ich will pünktlich von A nach
B gebracht werden, deswegen zeige ich mich da auch mit keinem solidarisch oder sonst
was, ich sage, ja, ihr dürft streiken, das ist absolut in Ordnung, ich habe da kein Problem,
dass ihr an sich das streikt, aber ich muss mich nicht jetzt auch noch sagen, jawoll,
macht weiter, macht weiter, ihr könnt mich alle machen, ich will, dass ihr mich pünktlich
von A nach B bringt, übrigens für das Jahresticket, wo ich auch bezahlt habe, der einzige und
alleine hinter dem ich da stehe sind die Fahrgäste, inklusive mir, übrigens, ich habe meine Privilege
schon komplett durchgecheckt, deswegen mache ich ja auch ab 01.09. jetzt offiziell, also
mit Vertragsänderungen mehr Homeoffice, dass ich diesen ganzen Scheiß hier nicht mehr brauche,
so, ich muss mich mit keinem solidarisch zeigen, außer mit mir, dass ich pünktlich von A nach
B komme, können mich alle machen, ich habe letztens mal geguckt, ich fand es so schlecht,
hat ein Lokführer gar nicht verdient, aber gut, die können das machen, ich spreche
ihnen ja nicht irgendwie, ich will ihnen ja nicht absprechen, dass sie das machen sollen
oder dass man die Leute ordentlich bezahlen sollte, selbstverständlich sollte man das,
aber ich muss sie nicht anfeuern, so nach dem Motto, ja, super, macht noch weiter, nein,
ich will pünktlich von A nach B kommen, die Umstände sind mir vollkommen wurscht, ja,
ob da jetzt der Profaller selbst anrückt und ins Hoch fährt oder wir wissen es mir scheiß
egal, ich will von A nach B kommen, pünktlich, das ist alles, so, also jetzt gucken wir uns
einmal ein paar Witze an, so, rechatten wir Windows 10 ist nice, why gamers are switching
to high DPI, das muss ich mir jetzt angucken, da bin ich nämlich auch mal gespannt, was
sie da machen, also ich bin immer noch, also ich bin immer noch auf 800 DPI, guckt, ich
bin auf, wo steht es denn, ich bin auf 800 DPI.
So a while ago I made a video showing that the click latency difference between wired
and wireless gaming mice was basically nothing to consider, there was no correlation showing
that wireless gaming mice was slower than wired as some people, was, why, ich verstehe
das Wort nicht, was für eine wild gaming mouse, was, as some people still believe today
and really more than anything it's the debounce delay of the mouse that has the biggest impact
on click latency more than anything, so for those that we are currently using or considering
upgrading to a wireless gaming mouse, ach so, wireless, aah, but there is one thing missing
from that testing and it's when it comes to the sensor and with a lot of gaming mice becoming
wireless and a lot of new brands coming to the market, you have to wonder if all sensors
and firmware are made equally, are all modern sensors actually the same, are they all good
enough and what does that mean when it comes to sensor latency, well to start answering
at least a few of these questions I built this, it's a belt driven machine which can independently
control a gaming mouse, hey, hey, das hat auch Dings letztens auch gemacht, ehm, ehm,
wie hieß der, wie heißt der, war das Battle Nonsense, nee, ehm, haben wir so letztens
das Video anguckt von, nicht Linux Tech Tips, nein, nein, ein Deutscher, der macht englischsprachige
Videos, ach ich hab's vergessen, der hat auch letztens sowas gemacht, haben sich alle
bei ihm abgeguckt, nein, nicht der Bauer, ja, Arduino, die coolen Leute verwenden ESP32,
Arduino in 2021, also,
ehm, und wie lassen sie den Bildschirm flashen, das kann ja, das sagen wir mal so, ehm, Refresh
Rate und sonst wie was, das kann durchaus mal 16 Millisekunden Delay eben je nachdem
wie sie das machen, ja, ziemlich genau, ziemlich, ziemlich gut, ziemlich, ziemlich gut, ziemlich
gut, ja, das ist ziemlich gut, gerade bei Bildschirm Refresh Rates und wie so immer,
dann ist das Delay ja nicht immer gleich, je nachdem, je nachdem, wenn du sagst, ehm,
jetzt Bildschirm rot machen und das liegt in deinem Grafikspeicher und der Bildschirm
Refresh Instant, weil das halt gerade passt oder 15 Sekunden, 15 Millisekunden später
dann, ok, aber wahrscheinlich, ach guck mal, der hat sein Bildschirm irgendwie auf 360
Hertz stehen oder sowas, ja gut, dann ist das glaube ich zu vernachlässigen, wie viel
ist das, wie lang ist ein Bild Refresh 360 Hertz, sag mal, bei 60 sind 16 Millisekunden
glaube ich, ne, so 16 Millisekunden versus, sind das 2,3 Millisekunden, ja, 2,7 Millisekunden,
ok, dann ist das wirklich so im Bereich, das sind wo ich sage, ey, scheiß drauf, also
übrigens krass, ne, das muss man sich immer mal wieder vergegenwärtigen, wie langsam
eigentlich ein Bildschirm ist, selbst ein 360 Hertz Bildschirm hat zwischen den Bildern
ungefähr 3 Millisekunden, in 3 Millisekunden kannst du dein Netzwerkpaket vom Rechner
daheim nach Frankfurt zum Gameserver und zurückschicken, ja, ungefähr in 3 Millisekunden,
wenn du jetzt mal irgendwelche Latency von Router und so außen vorlässt, also sprich,
du brauchst ein 360 Hertz Display, dass dein Bildaufbau lokal bei dir vor deinen Augen
ähnlich schnell ist wie ein Netzwerkpaket ins nächste Rechenzentrum, also Bildschirm
Refresh Rate war, also jetzt weniger, aber war schon immer verdammt langsam, überlegt
euch mal zu Zeiten von 60 Hertz, du hast 16 Millisekunden gebraucht, 16 Millisekunden
gebraucht für ein Bildrefresh, 16 Millisekunden, da ist dein Paket, ja gut, nicht in China,
aber irgendwo im Nahen Osten und zurück in der Zeit, wo du ein Frame Refreshst auf
deinem 60 Hertz Bildschirm, dein Paket ist in Russland und zurück, wenn du eine gute
Route erwischst, ja, was habe ich denn für, so pingen wir mal kurz 8888, 8888 ist übrigens
immer ein ganz guter Hubs, ein ganz guter Test, weil, ok, jetzt sind es 12, es schwankt
ein bisschen, wisst ihr warum 8888 ein guter Test ist für so Zeiten, weil das über Anycast
über die ganze Welt verteilt ist, also sprich, wenn ihr 8888 anpingt, dann kommt ihr höchst
wahrscheinlich bei einem anderen Server raus, wie wenn ich das mache oder zumindest bei
einem anderen Server raus, wie wenn ich das aus den USA mache oder aus Afghanistan mache
oder aus China mache oder so, also 8888, diesen Server gibt es mehrfach auf der Welt, also
es ist jetzt nicht so, als gibt es den nur einmal, es gibt diesen Server mit der gleichen
IP mehrfach auf der Welt, am besten immer irgendwo in der Nähe, wahrscheinlich im Dezix
in Frankfurt in Deutschland, mindestens einer.
Das ist CMDA, das ist eine etwas schickere Windausstelle, so ähnlich wie eine Domäne,
ne, Domäne wird ja aufgelöst zu einer IP und das ist eine IP, die mehrfach vorhanden
ist auf
Aber die Standard-Deviation schrinkt auch eine bemerkungsvolle Anzahl.
Mit dem Maus-Sensor auf nur 100 DPI
bekommen wir ca. 25,7 Millisekunden Maus-Movement auf dem Bildschirm
aber mit einigen Readings über 30 Millisekunden.
Ich kenne niemanden, der auf 100 DPI spielt.
Welchen Browser verwendest du? Ich verwende eigentlich alles Mögliche, von Firefox bis Chromium bis Chrome, wie Valdi hatte ich schon mal eine Weile, hauptsächlich verwende ich eigentlich Chromium, also den da, also quasi die etwas entgoogelte Variante von Chrome und Firefox.
Chromium ein bisschen mehr, aber sag mal so 60-70% Chromium oder Chrome-based und auf, also wir reden jetzt auf dem Desktop und auf so 30% Firefox.
Allerdings mobile sieht es anders aus, mobile ich meine ich habe ein iPhone und ein iPad, das heißt ich kann ja nur Safari verwenden, was anderes gibt es ja nicht.
There is about a 2-2.5 millisecond difference in sensor latency. The latency benefits then trail off the higher that you raise DPI. 1600 gives us a further 1.7 millisecond improvement over 800 DPI, but 3200 DPI only gives us about a half millisecond improvement on average.
Das habe ich jetzt nicht gecheckt. Also es geht jetzt um die Latency, wann die Maus die Bewegung, also wann angefangen wird Bewegung zu erkennen oder?
Also sprich ab wann erkennt die Maus die Bewegung als Bewegung oder verstehe ich das falsch?
It's pretty cool for me to measure and be able to show you these differences, it's not enough for me to convince you to bump up your Maus DPI.
However another factor at play here is the actual movement speed of the Maus. The results that you've seen so far.
Ja natürlich, natürlich wenn du die Maus schneller bewegst, ein niedriger DPI Sensor und wenn du die Maus schneller, also wenn du so machst, dann wird das langsamer sein als wenn du so machst, klar.
Genau, du brauchst einfach bei niedriger DPI mehr Movement als Movement, also mehr Fläche für ein Movement, dementsprechend musst du auch größere Fläche moveen, dass es als Movement erkannt wird und dementsprechend dauert mehr Fläche moveen, dauern länger.
Oder aus einer anderen Perspektive, wenn du an ein anderes Ziel oder ein anderes Ziel flichst im Spiel. Aber was ist, wenn du deinen Maus weniger bewegst? Zum Beispiel, wenn du nur den Riss bewegst, um einen Gegner an einer moderaten oder langen Distanz zu tracken.
Mit weniger Maus Bewegung gibt es weniger Informationen für den Maus Sensor, und also könnte ein höherer DPI hier mehr nötig sein.
Glücklicherweise können wir das testen, indem wir einfach die Geschwindigkeit des Motores verändern. Und wie wir erwartet haben, die Differenzen in den Resultaten wachsen, mit dem höheren DPI Sensor zeigen, dass es mehr nötig ist, um die Latentierung zu reduzieren, wenn du einen schnelleren Maus Bewegung hast.
Ja gut, 100 DPI ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen zu viel des Guten. 100 DPI ist dann erstmal... Leute, ich laufe mal kurz mit der Maus durchs ganze Haus. Ich bin gleich wieder da, dann habe ich den 360 gemacht.
So, ich bin jetzt im Garten hinten angekommen. So, ich bin jetzt vorne wieder am Hoftor. Ich gehe jetzt noch mal kurz den Keller rüber. Jetzt renne ich die Treppe wieder hoch. Ah, okay, 360 gemacht.
Also, 100 DPI ist ja wirklich... 100 DPI bist du ja nur am kurbeln, wenn du dich da drehen willst.
Also, 100 DPI kannst du ja vergessen. Das Leistungssport... Athleten hassen diesen Trick. Ich spiele auch 800.
Ist das... Ist die Sensitivity linear bei den meisten Games, wenn man den Slider verstellt?
Offensichtlich. Ja, das ist mir zu sicher.
Das Ding heißt wirklich Pwnage Ultra Custom.
Wirklich?
Wo ist denn meine, wo ist denn meine, meine Pro Wireless?
Steht die da irgendwo, ist die da dabei?
Nee, ne, gibt's nicht.
Doch G Pro, das ist die G Pro Wireless, aber nicht, aber nicht Superlight.
Also da muss man doch mal echt sagen, das ist doch nur wirklich kein Unterschied.
Zu wired. 20,3 zu 19,8.
Ja, seh ich auch so, das ist die, die ich hab, das ist meine, genau, die hab ich, ne die nicht.
Jetzt noch, genau, PS2, das ist die, die ich hab, das ist meine, genau, die hab ich, ne die nicht.
Jetzt noch, genau, PS2-Mouse noch vergleichen, please.
Wireless-Champ.
Sollte ich mal gucken, ob ich irgendwas feststelle zwischen 800 DPI, wobei es dann problematisch wird,
dann ist ja, und das stimmt ja unter Windows meine, meine Geschwindigkeit wieder nicht.
Wenn ich das jetzt hier hochstelle auf keine Ahnung, 1600, dann ist das ja unter Windows doppelt so schnell.
Und ich will meine Windows-Sensitivity nicht umstellen.
Ich glaube ich bleibe bei 800 DPI, das funktioniert, da bin ich dran gewöhnt, da treffe ich mir
wenigstens ein bisschen was. So, next. Bank-Level-Technology versus Magnet.
Okay, der darf nicht fehlen, der darf nicht fehlen. 3 is binding, click on 4.
Wie alt ist diese G Pro Software? Ich hab die nie aktualisiert, nachdem ich sie mal installiert hab.
Die ist uralt, das ist Software von, steht gar nicht mal da, es ist Software von, keine Ahnung,
wo sieht man das, Einstellungen, wo sieht man die Software-Version, Info, 9.02 von 2018, reicht doch.
So aktuell genug.
Ich könnte das mal updaten vielleicht. Warum ich das noch benutze, ganz einfach,
weil ich es installiert habe, 2018. Vielleicht sollte ich mal, vielleicht sollte ich mal das neu installieren.
This is the Lockpicking Lawyer and what I have for you today is a WeHear brand key lockbox that advertises quote banking one-time password technology.
Natürlich.
This sells on Amazon for $80, but they also have a lot of...
Wir wissen beide, oder was heißt Chat, also ihr und ich, wir wissen beide, das wird nicht funktionieren.
...sizes ranging up to $160.
Das Video ist so zwei Minuten lang.
Now I had little doubt that I could get into this with the cheap wafer lock we find on the side,
but I was really interested in the electronic mechanism with its quote bank level technology.
Now I'm not really qualified to evaluate the strength of the one-time passwords,
but I figured that if they put serious effort into that, it was more likely that the mechanism was adequate.
Well, that reasoning turned out to be incorrect.
The locking cam holding the door closed is secured with a little solenoid,
essentially a small plunger activated by an electromagnet.
Well, as you might imagine, that...
Bank level technology ist halt auch so ein sinnloser Ausdruck, sagt der Chat.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Das ist genauso, wie wenn Netzwerkequipment verkauft wird und dabei erzählt wird,
so nach dem Motto mit Technologie aus der Raumfahrt und so Bullshit.
...can also be activated by a sufficiently powerful external magnet.
Let's give that a try.
Currently locked.
And just that quickly we unlocked it.
Let's do that one more time so you can see it was not a fluke.
Once again locked.
And highly secure.
Easy.
Just to round things out, let's also rake open this wafer lock.
I'm going to be using...
Alter, der hat es innerhalb von 1,5 Minuten doppelt geknackt.
Vorne und neben.
...from the Genesis set that I sell over on CovertInstruments.com.
It's a double-sided wafer lock, so we're going to need to rake the bottom and top.
Jetzt wackelt er gleich drin.
That was the bottom.
That was the top.
Easy.
Easy as, easy, easy as f**k.
Okay, folks, obviously this doesn't provide much...
Ich hoffe, meine Bank hat das Geld nicht da drin.
...security and shouldn't be viewed as anything more than a key organizer.
Eigentlich müsste dieses Schloss so gedruckt werden.
Genau so.
In any case, that's all I have for you today.
If you do have any questions or comments about this, please put them below.
If you liked this video and would like to see more like it, please subscribe.
And as always, have a nice day.
Thank you.
So, jetzt wirst du auch wieder Bescheid.
Also wir wissen jetzt, dass die es wieder nicht auf die Reihe kriegen.
Was haben wir denn jetzt hier?
Fünf HTML tags, die man noch nicht gesehen hat.
Okay, bin ich mal gespannt.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass...
480p?
Haben die das mit einem Nokia-Phone aufgenommen, oder was?
Bei Microsoft?
Alas, da kann ich mir das nicht...
Gar nicht mehr das für dich vorstellen.
Hallo?
Apple.
Keine Ahnung.
Hab ich noch nie verwendet.
Wusste nicht, dass es das gibt.
Korrekt.
BDO.
MonkaS.
Hab ich auch noch nie gehört.
Ach.
Muss ich auch nicht.
Das kenn ich.
Da kann man Shortcuts mit anzeigen.
Das hab ich schon mal verwendet.
Das kenn ich.
Warum ist es nicht das SIM-Tag?
Ups, das hab ich erst gemacht.
Hab ich noch nie verwendet.
Ich war schon mal da.
Das hab ich schon mal verwendet.
ne wieder wird wieder kein menschen interessieren field fans call of duty vanguard's marketing is
weird cyber punks latest update was bigger than expected and much more dice are probably planning
a big production battle field 2042 at gamescom next week to date they've shown gameplay of the core
multiplayer experience all-out warfare we've also gotten snippets of gameplay from the portal custom
game mode but hazard zone is still entirely under wraps the recent short film exodus set up the
events behind the games backstory and served as a hint about what players will do in hazard zone
the characters mentioned having to recover a crash satellite in doha qatar that's the location of
2042 hourglass map since then data miner temporary al has discovered several files in the 2042
test build related to hazard zone according to him it's a hybrid of hunt showdown and escape
objectives to accomplish soldiers will roam the map serving as resistance to players and as many
objectives as well temporary al hasn't explained the PvP mechanics of hazard zone but dice describe
it as a high stakes squad based mode temporary al has found evidence of loadout insurance and
respawn systems so it sounds like there will be a big emphasis on staying alive during a match as
for why we expect a hazard zone reveal at gamescom it's pretty much tradition for dice to reveal
gameplay of their new titles at the convention they've done it for almost every past battlefield
and all signs point to hazard zone as the next big reveal the exodus short film was practically an
ad for the mode as well really hazard zone is the last piece of the battlefield 2042 puzzle and
gamescom is the only major gaming convention between now and when 2042 launches so personally
i'm expecting a hazard zone reveal dice is also likely to announce beta dates for 2042 at gamescom
we know that there will be a beta next month but we're just not sure when pre-order customers and
ea play subscribers will get early beta access during club übrigens übrigens ich wurde angeschrieben von
ja nicht direkt von ea von von der marketing agentur zwischen ea und dixie man das ja alles
nicht mehr selbst ob ich nicht an einem hands-on event teilnehmen möchte dass ich battlefield 2042
ausprobieren kann bevor die beta start habe ich gesagt natürlich will ich da dran teilnehmen
gib her aber ich vermute mal dass ich das nicht streamen und nicht zeigen darf wieder sessions
aber es wäre aber cool wenn man da schon capturen darf damit man gleich zu betas start gameplay
hat das wäre sehr nice it's a pretty exciting time to be a battlefield fan despite the alleged
performance issues and bugs with the recent technical playtests it seems like das neue
video nach dem stream ich habe schon hochgeladen wir haben uns sogar schon eine minute teaser
draus angeguckt a groundbreaking entry in the franchise fingers crossed the beta leaves a good
first impression on all players call of duty vanguard was revealed and while it mostly aligned
with the rumors and expectations leading up to the official trailer one interesting thing stood
out about the game smart total oft empfohlen bekommen soll ich merken ich habe es mir noch
nicht angeguckt also dieses dieses jahr call of duty und gerade das es könnte mich fast nichts
kälter lassen marketing the official call of duty twitter account made to post advertising vanguard
will offer a new pc anti cheat system to say it's unprecedented for a developer to use their
anti cheat solution as a marketing point would be seriously understating things the outrage
cheat in warzone ist klar warzone lack of effective anti cheat has been bubbling over for nearly a
year at this point many players and content creators alike have abandoned the battle royale was
halt komplett lächerlich ist warum brauchen die neues call of duty release um ordentlich
anticheat einzubauen das ist einfach nur marketing so nach dem auto ja es gibt anticheat wir kaufen
uns jetzt das hätten die ohne probleme wenn es was taugen würde hätten schon längst machen
können es wird aber wahrscheinlich auch nichts ändern dran captain peng langsche für den sub
station despite banning hundreds of thousands of cheaters and making it harder to buy new accounts
call of duties developers have failed to make a substantial impact on the cheating epidemic in
their games advertising a new anti-cheat system for their upcoming game hopefully means that
they're taking things extremely seriously nine nine years new anti-cheat system implemented
with warzone when the two games are integrated unfortunately it doesn't sound like that will
happen at long by the way ich ich ich ich ich wollte jetzt einfach sagen also kein flugzeug
träger im zweiten weltkrieg falls es diese in dieser form überhaupt gab war so voll und in
dieser art und weise bestückt mit flugzeugen wie soll das denn funktionieren sollen die alle
ineinander fahren oder was was ist das das gruppenkurs mit flugzeugen oder was soll denn das sein
also it doesn't sound like that will happen at launch on november 5th the games marketing
surrounding the warzone integration highlights a brand new map and continued support for existing
content but it doesn't confirm the integration is happening at launch or even when players can
expect that integration to happen another interesting point is that the activision logo
is nowhere in vanguard's trailer or associated marketing they officially explained it as a
creative choice that reflects how vanguard represents the next major installment in the
franchise but it's pretty obvious that activision's name is deeply unpopular given the workplace
harassment lawsuit that they're currently facing overall the vanguard reveal is a very mixed bag
sledgehammer games are developing it and their track record with the franchise is well kind of
mediocre warzone is in a rough state there's serious competition from the likes of battlefield
and halo which are pushing a more modern aesthetic and setting ich würde ohne scheiße ich würde es
halo wirklich gönnen dass sie irgendwas auf die reihe bekommen dort
bisschen bisschen spieler spieler schafft abzugreifen
das bild das bild mag zwar sein aber gestartet ist davon keiner kein flugzeug ist davon irgendwie
großartig gestartet in so wie die dass das das also hat gerade es hat gerade im chat ein bild
gepostet wie sollen die dann davon starten wie sollen das wie sollen das funktionieren
das hier reicht ja das hier reicht also erstens wie sollen die landen und zweitens wie sollen
die starten der transport mag sein aber im call of duty trailer hatten die ihre propeller an also
das mag ja zum transport sinne ergeben aber das was die dort anders gezeigt haben nicht
nehmen sie ihre own thoughts in the comments below halo infinite will not launch with the franchises typical co-op campaign or forage modes 343 announced this in a development update video the co-op campaign is planned for the game season two update forage is planned for season three each season will be about three months which means the co-op campaign will probably launch in early 2022 obviously this is a
Das ist eine große Zufriedenheit für die Leute, die sich durch die Halo-Kampagnen mit einem
Freund verabschieden.
Cyberpunk 2077s 1.3 Update ist viel mehr wichtig als die originalen Patchnoten.
Fast alle Moden für das Spiel verbrachten mit 1.3.
Beide Modder und Dataminier fanden sich das Update an, um herauszufinden, was genau verändert
und es turns out, dass die Antwort, ja, fast alles ist.
CD Projekt RED hat große Teile des Spiels für dieses Update aufgeschrieben.
In Bezug auf die Größe des Spiels ist das nicht so unerwartet, aber es ist ein guter
Zeichen, dass wirkliche Prognose gemacht wird.
Ein weiterer guter Zeichen ist, dass Dataminier die Erfindung des Multiplayer wieder in der
Entwicklung ist.
CD Projekt RED hat die originalen Modder indefinit belästigt, bis die Multiplayer-Experienz
im März zurückgekommen ist.
Diese originale Multiplayer-Mode wurde als Cyberpunk Online in den Spielen des Spiels
bezeichnet.
Nach dem Auslaufen der Modder wurde in den Spielen in den Spielen gespürt, aber das
1.3-Update hat sie entfernt.
Dataminier haben eine neue Stange für den Modder gefunden, die es Multi-Mode nennt.
Das sieht aus wie eine große Verabschiedung des Multiplayer-Projekts des Spiels aus, da
die Entwickler oft keine großen Features mehr nennen, außer wenn es eine Veränderung
in Richtung gibt.
Cyberpunks Multiplayer wird wahrscheinlich nach dem zweiten Teil der DLC-Expansion
nächsten Jahr auslaufen.
Es war eine große Woche für Bethesda und id Software.
Sie haben eine genaue Remaster von Quake 1, Doom Eternals 6.66-Update eröffnet und Skyrim
bekommt noch ein weiteres Releas, welches Fisch anbietet.
Quake-Fans präsentieren die Remaster, die von Nightdive Studios entwickelt wurde und
eine Expansion von Wolfenstein Devs Machine Games anbietet.
Es bietet eine moderne Accessibilität zu dem klassischen Spiel, während es aufgeteilt
ist.
Und was ich auch gelesen habe, Always-On, du brauchst ja zum Quake 1 zu spielen, musst
du Always-On sein.
Weiß nicht, ob das stimmt, hab ich gelesen, kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Always-On, für ein Game, zu Zeiten, wo On überhaupt noch kein Begriff war.
Noch mehr Skyrim, Alter, wie oft wollt ihr noch Skyrim machen, es ist ja irgendwann
mal gut.
Irgendwann ist doch mal Schluss mit Skyrim, was gibt's denn da jetzt schon alles, Legendary
Edition, Gold Edition, Super Premium Edition, Anniversary Edition, Alter, das gibt's für
alles, es gibt fast keine Plattform, wo es keinen Skyrim gibt mittlerweile.
Pass mal auf, irgendwann kommt raus, dass das Elder Scrolls 6 ist dann, nee warte mal,
was war Skyrim 5, ach keine Ahnung, das nächste Elder Scrolls ist dann quasi Skyrim, die 20
Jahre Edition.
Es gibt auch eine neue Expansion und 500 Creation Club Mods, die all sorts of new weapons, spells,
Quest-Bosses, Fishing und mehr anbieten.
Destiny 2s Ammo System hat einen großen Überfall.
Primary Weapons haben Infinite Ammo für die nächste Saison.
Einige minere Balance Veränderungen werden für diese Veränderung ausgemacht, die bestimmte
Perken ausgebufft haben.
Die nächste Saison startet am 24.
Digital Foundry hat die Zeit mit dem Crysis 3 Remaster mit einem Nintendo Switch.
They say it's a major upgrade from the original version of the game and runs at a solid 30
FPS on Nintendo's portable console.
The whole Crysis Trilogy is getting a remaster following the launch of Crysis 1 Remastered.
The PC versions of Crysis 2 and 3 are still benchmarks for the Switch, but console players
have been stuck with inferior versions for a very long time.
These remasters will offer massively improved performance and visuals on last and current
gen consoles.
Before we get to our final story this week, I wanted to say thanks for tuning in.
We'll have complete coverage of all Gamescom Battlefield 2042 news, so stay tuned for that.
Saints Row is getting a reboot.
The cult classic third person action franchise has made a name for itself as the Grand Theft
Auto but crazier series over the years.
Saints Row III recently got a remaster that was a complete remake and hinted at future
games in development.
The developers are now teasing a reboot to be revealed at Gamescom.
It's unclear if the reboot is a sequel or a total reimagining of the entire franchise.
Saints Row IV got its final expansion back in 2015.
The devs teased a new game was in the works during their 2019 financial report, but this
is the first public teaser we've gotten for the fifth game.
And that wraps it up for this week in gaming.
As always guys, thank you so much for watching and I'll catch you next time, this is Levelcap.
The best-paid professions and industries I think I'm too stonky today.
What?
Question.
Did you add a few Shelly for Strom and Temps for fun?
Not bad.
I like them.
Write a few applications yourself that create something in the Postgrespark and with Grafama
create a dashboard, or is there a Ready-to-Go-Solution?
Well, Grafama is pretty ready to go, but I would recommend InfluxDB as a database.
Oh, not really Postgres for that, you can use Postgres, they even have a time-series
extension now.
But Influx should be the easier one, that's exactly what it's made for.
Or, even easier, there might be a ready-made Prometheus exporter, then you can use that.
If you want to use Prometheus as a monitoring solution.
So for Shelly's there's no- There's no guarantee for anything.
Shelly-Prometheus-Exporter.
Okay, he really doesn't have a good rating.
Tja, also ich würde es so machen, ganz ehrlich, ich würde die Shellys einfach in mein Home
Assistant integrieren, und das, was die standardmäßig unterstützen, eben benutzen, und damit wäre
ich wahrscheinlich zu 95% glücklich.
Shelly hat, du hast die MQTT-Integration, du hast die Shelly-Integration, einfach in Home
Assistant einbinden und gut ist.
Mehr braucht man eigentlich nicht.
Prometheus spricht man nicht Prometheus, ja ich weiß, aber das ist mir zu dumm, außerdem
kann ich das auf Deutsch aussprechen, auf Deutsch spricht man es Prometheus aus.
Der Panzer-Satan ist wieder hart am flamen hier, passt ja dein Name dazu.
So, Solar-Panels, was haben wir da so, Do-It-Yourself-Smart-Home-Video-Klöngel, die habe ich nur aufgemacht, weil
die Vorschau mal wirklich nach jemand aussieht, der Ahnung hat von dem, was er macht.
Die meisten Selbstbau dieser Projekte sind ultra gebastelt, wo ich mir immer denke,
nach zwei Monaten sind die kaputt.
Das hier Hausnummer, do this, ok zeig mal her, was macht meine Hausnummer, jawoll RGB-Hausnummer,
das habe ich gebraucht.
Die Hausnummer in RGB, endlich, Leute soll ich euch mal, da ist WLED drauf, da ist garantiert
WLED drauf von den Effekten her, das finde ich cool, das finde ich cool, sowas brauche
ich auch, das brauche ich auch, ok, was hat er da gekauft, warte mal, bevor wir das Video
durchskippen, ich will mal gucken, was er sich für Teile gekauft hat, hier, China-Chinesen-Hausnummer,
jawoll, die China-Chinesen-Hausnummer, die brauchen wir, ok, ich leake jetzt nicht meine
Hausnummer, ich leake jetzt mal random was an, 2, bam, 30 cm, wie groß hat der sich
gekauft, 20 cm, 20 cm reicht ja auch, 38 € per Sand, das ist so geil, Premium Shipping
kostet einfach mehr und ist langsamer.
Bitte wählen Sie alle Produktoptionen, was habe ich denn noch nicht gewählt, ok, mach
keinen Unterschied, das kostet alles so viel, ich brauche ja auch davon 2, also das kann
ich leaken, ich habe eine zweistellige Hausnummer, ABCD, also ich müsste mir 2 kaufen, das heißt,
es kostet mich allein schon mal 80 €, nur die 2 Hausnummern zu machen, meine Hausnummer,
ja 69, natürlich, was sonst, so 420 würde uns dann sogar 120 € kosten, Safe ist das
verboten in Deutschland Hausnummern anzuhängen, hä, warum sollte das verboten sein, man hat
doch eine Hausnummer am Haus, warum sollte das verboten sein, eine leuchtende Hausnummer
zu haben.
Chainloy ist wieder, Big Brain Time am Start, wo ist der Unterschied zwischen 6 und 9, das
ist eine gute Frage, die hat einen kürzeren Strich, oder, ansonsten könnte man sie einfach
anders aufhängen, ich finde das mega geil, das brauche ich, das brauche ich, was viele
Hausnummern sind, was, viele Hausnummern sind vorschriftswidrig, wir haben aber echt für
jeden Scheiß irgendwas, oder, einige Gemeinden und Bundesländer schreiben beleuchtete Hausnummern
voll, ja easy, easy, RGB Hausnummer, sag ich doch, beste.
Ja, wunderbar, so, dann gucken wir uns das jetzt mal kurz an, also, wie hat er das gebaut,
wie hat er das gebaut, dieser Beat im Hintergrund, Rap Gott, es hat was, es hat was, ich will
eigentlich nur sehen, wie er das baut, ok, Microcontroller und, ja hat er die LEDs,
sind die LEDs da drinnen, oder hat er die da zusätzlich reingemacht, ah, hier zeigt
das, ja, Heißkleber immer, immer Heißkleber, Heißkleber, wenn was nicht hält, einfach
Heißkleber drauf, das leuchtet ja wie im Club, genau, ah, das war so cringe, das Telekom
Video, ja, wie hat er das, wie, das ist aber nicht in den USA, das ist ja eine richtige
Wand, das muss irgendwo in Europa sein, das kann er mir nicht erzählen, dass das in den
USA ist, Niederlande, ja, das passt schon eher, ah, Niederlande, Niederlande, ok, es war
klar, dass es kein Kekonahaus sein kann, brauche ich nicht, brauche ich nicht, wisst ihr warum
ich das nicht brauche, weil ich schon mal in weißer Voraussicht, falls ich mal sowas
machen will, die letzten beiden verbliebenen Adernpaare zu meiner Türklingel vorne so gelegt
habe, dass ich dran komme, wenn ich die brauche, und dann kann ich innen einfach eine 12 Volt
Netzzeit anschließen und es da drüber leiten und oben anschließen, der hat doch, Moment,
Moment, der hat doch seinen Controller bestimmt in der Hausnummer drinnen, oder? Oder hat
er seinen Controller innen? Ich hoffe mal, der hat die, was ist das?
Hat er den Controller drinnen oder nicht? Der hat, der hat den Controller nicht in der
Hausnummer, der hat den Controller innen, sonst würde da nicht die drei Kabel raus
werden, das ist die typische LED, typische LED Kabel, ja, plus minus Control, also wahrscheinlich
sind das 5 Volt LEDs, ihr plus 5 Volt, minus 5, also plus, minus, und ihr Datenleitung,
das heißt, er macht den Controller innen rein. Da habe ich nicht genug Leitung für
das, das ist doof, und ich will kein Loch durch die Wand bohren, ich habe kein Borkenloch
durch die Wand zu bohren.
Das sieht sogar relativ sauber, sauber verlegt aus, was sie da gemacht haben. Ich habe gar
keinen Bohrer dafür, was braucht man denn da für einen Bohrer? Da komme ich, da komme
ich mit meinem 12 Volt Aguschrauber wahrscheinlich nicht weit, um sowas da durch die Wand zu
bohren.
Ich habe nur meinen Bosch GBR 12 Volt. Ich müsste den Controller in die Nummer bauen,
falls der hier reinpasst. Wenn du doch Kabel drin hast, kannst du Kabel nachziehen, ne so
einfach ist es nicht. Ja, zeig mal hier. Ok, jetzt wird es festzementiert oder sowas, wird
das mega nice, ich will das auch haben. So, wo ist die Technik? Technik? Technik, ok, das
ist irgendwie so ein fertiger LED. Guck mal hier, richtige Twanz mit ADN Hülsen drauf.
Wer macht das denn so ordentlich, ey? Einfach reinschrauben und gut ist. Scheiß auf Widerstand.
Was hat er für Netzteile? Ja sagst du, 5 Volt LED ist ja ein gutes Reiz. 6 Ampere ist
vielleicht, das brauchst du nie im, na doch, doch, tatsächlich. Ich betreibe die, also
du kannst die auch weniger, aber dann werden sie halt, es ist halt dunkler, dann ist halt
weniger maximale Helligkeit. Und gerade dein Schild draußen, deine Hausnummer, willst
ja, dass die schön hell ist. Ja, 6 Ampere ist dann doch. Also meine Weihnachtsfensterbeleuchtung
ist an einem 5 Volt, 10 Ampere Netzteil dran. Seit wann hat Max einen ähnlichen Channel?
Ok, der hat das wirklich innen drin gemountet, den LED Controller. Was find ich jetzt irgendwie
ein bisschen blöd? Unpraktisch, sag mal mal unpraktisch. Auf der anderen Seite, ich werd
nicht drumherum, guck mal, wie er da einfach ein Loch in der Mitte hat. Ich werd wahrscheinlich
nicht drumherum kommen, da ein Loch durch die Wand zu bohren, wenn ich sowas machen
will. Weil ich hab zwar hier unten auch meine Türgegensprecher in der Lage, wo ich noch
ein paar Adern frei hab, aber dann müsste ich die ja an der Wand langlegen, nach oben.
Das wär vielleicht auch nicht so, so clever, oder? Ich glaub an der Außenwand so aufputz,
kabellang legen ist auch nicht so geil. Da müsste man irgendwie schauen, dass man da
durch die Wand durchkommt. Was braucht man da? Leute, was braucht man da für nen Bohrer?
Ich mein jetzt den Bohrer, nicht den Akku, also nicht die Bohrmaschine. Muss zweimal
bohren bei zwei Ziffern, nee. Na wobei, vielleicht doch. Außer ich leg das clever. Was für nen
Bohrer braucht man denn da? Also ich red jetzt wie gesagt nicht von dem eigentlichen Gerät,
sondern von dem Bohrer an sich. Das Betonbohrer. Ich brauch was langes, Alter. So. Bohrer lang
Wand. Was da? Ich brauch sowas richtig, so genau, so lange Dinger brauch ich, dass ich
auf die Wand komme. 20 cm, bam. Bohrer 5,5 mm, jawoll. Wow. 50 cm, zack. Neu verputzen,
das krieg ich nicht gebacken. Sowas da, jawoll. Ich weiß wo die Leitungen sind, da sind keine.
Ich hab ja so nen Leitungscheckding. Ist aber geil, sonst brauch ich sowas. Was gibt's
im Kopf? Ein Meter Bohrer, bam. Gibt's ja wirklich. Na klar, warum soll's es nicht geben. Da hat
man wenigstens was. Die Frage ist halt, was du für ne Wand hast. Ja, das ist nicht so
einfach zu beantworten. Das Haus ist schon ein bisschen älter und der Opa hat das genommen
an Materialien, was er gerade da hatte. Also das Erdgeschoss, das ist gebaut von meinem
Urur-Opa oder so und mein Opa hat da ein bisschen weiter dran rumgebaut und der hat
halt das genommen, was gerade da war. Also die Steine sind nicht überall die gleichen
Steine. Also das kann ich definitiv nicht mit meinem 12 Volt Akkuschrauber machen. Oder,
wenn ich's ganz langsam mach, vielleicht mit meinem 12 Volt Akkuschrauber. Max, wie alt
ist das Haus? Keine Ahnung, von 1900 oder so, das ist uralt. Na, reinpassen tut das schon,
aber die Kraft reicht da wahrscheinlich nicht aus. Niemals. Ne, glaub ich auch nicht, dass
das funktioniert. Warte mal, wo hat er das denn jetzt gebohrt? Hier. Hier. Okay, nope.
Das krieg ich mit meinem 12 Volt Akkuschrauber garantiert nicht hin. Am besten fachmännisch
erledigen lassen. Ich brauch doch kein Fachmann, um ein Loch in die Wand zu bohren, das krieg
ich selbst hin. Hast du einen Bohrhammer mit SDS-Aufnahme? Nö. Hab ich bis jetzt noch
nicht gebraucht. Ja, ich vermute mal, das ist keine so gute Idee.
Ich meine, ich find das mega geil mit der Hausnummer. Guck mal, ist das nicht stylisch,
so eine RGB-Hausnummer? Alter, das sieht doch richtig geil aus. Das ist doch schon nice.
Man muss es ja nicht übertreiben. Für was hat er das Loch in der Mitte gemacht? Ich
würde sagen, er hat sich verbohrt oder aber er will dort was anderes hinmachen, will seine
Hausnummer nicht leaken. Doch, ich kann die Leitung von der Türklingel nehmen, aber die
müsste ich dann irgendwie ja noch einen Meter weiter nach oben bekommen oder zwei Meter
nach oben bekommen von der Türklingel. Das heißt, ich müsste dann irgendwie an der Außenwand
da irgendwie zwei Kabel rauflegen oder so. Das ist doch doof. Als ob sowas nicht mehr
einfach mit Batterie gibt. Nee, die Batterie bringt dir ja nichts. Der Controller, der
die LEDs steuert, ist innen und nein, sowas wird es nicht einfach mit Batterie geben, weil
das braucht schon ein bisschen was an Strom. Guck mal, wenn das 60 LEDs pro Lampe sind,
pro Zahl, oder 30, wenn du 5 Volt, 6 Ampere hast und das ordentlich hell wird, dann sind
das, dann brauchst du 30 Watt glaube, 5 mal 6, dann brauchst du 30 Watt pro Nummer. Oder
wenn du es ein bisschen dunkler machst, sagen wir mal für 2, 30 Watt für 2, da machst du
nix mit Batterie. Da muss ja die ganze Nacht leuchten. In die Fugen legen und dann wieder
verschließen. Welche Fugen? Ich muss ja den ganzen Putz abmachen. Nee, nee, nee, nee,
das mach ich nicht. Das mach ich nicht, ich mach da keine, mach da nicht außen drauf irgendwelche
Kabel. Doch, richtig Pongers, das brauche ich. Das brauche ich. Das brauche ich. Ich will
jetzt aber eigentlich nur noch wissen, wie er da, na gut, er hat den Controller innen,
das hat man doch, hat man ja gesehen. Coole Idee, sehr coole Idee. Vielleicht bestelle
ich mir einfach mal auf gut Glück bei AliExpress 2 Nummern. Einfach nur, weil es geht. LED-Leisten
habe ich noch. LED-Strips habe ich noch da. Find ich mega Pongers. Was hat er da für
LED-Strips drin, dann zeig mal her. Ok. 28, gut, das macht da nicht so der Unterschied.
198 LEDs pro Meter, ja kein Wunder, dass der da 30 Watt bzw. 5 Volt, 6 Ampere pro Nummer
braucht. 200 LEDs pro Meter, fuck. Das ist brutal viel. Deswegen siehst du hier auch
nirgends die Übergänge zwischen den LEDs. Guck mal, Moment. Guck mal, die Chinesen,
die Chinesen haben sein Kram verlinkt. Oder wurde er gesponsert von den China-Chinesen.
Das kosten die LED-Strips. Ja, 15, 15, 15 Meter. Äh, ne, ne. LED-Strip 200 pro Meter.
Muss ich mal gucken, was ich da nehme. Aber ich finde, ich finde, das ist eine sehr coole
Geschichte. Das Hauptproblem wird nicht sein, das hier zu bauen. Das zu bauen ist glaube
ich relativ easy, sondern wie ich den Stromanschluss bzw. die Kabel da hin bekomme. Nice. Ja, ich
würde auch ein RGB-W-Strip nehmen. Ist das RGB-W? Wahrscheinlich nicht, ne. Äh, ja,
SK6812 habe ich noch da. Ja, dann nehme ich einen, der LED-Strips ich noch da habe. Das
ist ja kein Problem. Ähm, ja, aber trotzdem. Das Problem bei mir ist irgendwie, dass ich
die Kabel da hin bekomme. Da muss ich mir mal Gedanken machen. Okay, da gucke ich jetzt
noch mal mit den, mit den bei Solar-Panels. Das brauchen wir jetzt nicht. Da gucken wir
uns jetzt mal an Blizzards Niedergang. Wie sich, also das ganz ehrlich, mal unabhängig
von den aktuellen Sachen, die dabei bei Blizzard so abgehen. Blizzard hat sich, hat sich über
Jahre schon, hat sich über Jahre schon verkackt. Ich meine, der größte, es gibt ja zwei Fails,
die glaube ich die Leute immer noch im Kopf haben. Äh, you guys don't have phones und
Warcraft 3 reforged. Aber das ging ja schon viel früher los. Das war eigentlich klar
mit der Übernahme. Beziehungsweise, das war ja keine Übernahme, das war ein Merch. Äh,
zwischen äh, dem Blizzard-Teil von, wie hießen die, irgendwelche Franzosen, glaube ich waren
das wie Vendi und Activision. Und ich habe damals auch ein Video zugemacht und da wurde
ich geflamed unter dem Video, in den Comments. So nach dem Motto, Max, du hast das alles
ganz falsch verstanden. Es ist jetzt nicht etwa so, dass Blizzard bei Activision angestellt
ist, bla bla bla bla. Es war von Anfang an klar, dass immer mehr Stonks Activision-Manager
bei Blizzard einzugehalten werden, mit der Zeit. Und das hat man jetzt gesehen und wird
sich auch weiterhin so fortsetzen. Es ist kein Wunder, dass, äh, ich glaube alle Gründer
mittlerweile weg sind. Jeff Kaplan ist weg. Letztens ist jetzt ja noch der, der aktuelle
Chef zurückgetreten. Ist vorbei. Ja. Man hat es auch an der Qualität gesehen, was Blizzard
released hat. Früher hattest du den Eindruck, Blizzard Leute machen Spiele erstens, wenn
sie fertig sind und zweitens Spiele, die sie selber gerne spielen. Das hat man bis, sagen
wir mal so, StarCraft, StarCraft 2 gemerkt, das Originale. Ich rede nicht von den zwei
Addons. Ähm, und noch ein bisschen bei Overwatch. Aber ansonsten, eigentlich bei nichts mehr.
So, gucken wir mal. Ist ja ja schon lange nicht mehr. Ich hab letztens gesehen, weil
Upworkraft hat angeblich noch zwei Millionen Subs. Ob das stimmt? Keine Ahnung. Zahlen
kann man ja nicht glauben. Doch, genug. Die haben so viele, so viele, so viele, so viele
Fragen gebauen. Vielleicht waren sie auch die Jedi-R pech. Aber Schwierigkeit hat sich
Die haben dann so Dinger gemacht wie, wir bieten jetzt den World of Warcraft Skins an oder irgendwelche Microtransactions.
Also allein schon, dass World of Warcraft triple monetarisiert ist.
Also du musst Addons kaufen, du musst Monthly-Subscriptions bezahlen und du hast Microtransactions.
Allein schon das ist absolutes Unding. Das dürfte es meiner Meinung nach überhaupt nicht geben.
So und dann haben die so Dinger getrieben wie, für die BlizzCon wir machen ein Turnier.
Wir machen ein World of Warcraft PvP Turnier und die Erlöse der Skin-Verkäufe kommen zusätzlich obendrauf.
Und bis dann Blizzard gesagt hat, ja die Erlöse der Skin-Verkäufe kommen darüber raus, aber Preisgeld bezahlen wir dafür nicht mehr.
Es war ja ursprünglich eigentlich die Ansage, es gibt das Preisgeld plus die Erlöse von den Skin-Verkäufern dafür.
Die haben so viele so viele krumme Verarschungs-Dinger getrieben die letzten Jahre.
Nur die letzten drei Jahre konnte es halt auch der letzte Fanboy nicht mehr übersehen.
Wobei die Microtransactions keinen Gameplay Einfluss haben oder kommt drauf an wie man das definiert.
Wenn du sagst es sind OP-Items, dann wahrscheinlich nicht, aber es hat ja allein schon darauf Einfluss, dass du die kaufen kannst.
Und wenn du die erfarmen müsstest, ist halt die Frage ob die das Erfarmen nicht unnötig aufwendig machen, dass du die lieber kaufst als erfarmst.
Was dann schon einen Gameplay Einfluss hat.
Und gerade in einem Spiel, wo sich ja so viel mittlerweile um wer hat die coolste optische Ausrüstung dreht, es ist ein Unding.
Es sollte bei einem Game, das Addons verkauft plus Monthly-Subscription hat, es sollte einfach keinen Shop geben.
Ich meine einen Shop, sagen wir mal für Account-Transfers oder irgendwelche Dinge, die einen gewissen Aufwand verursachen, das ist okay.
Aber keine Ingame-Vorteile, keine Ingame-Item, nichts. Das muss alles erspielbar sein und für jeden die gleichen Voraussetzungen.
Im Jahr 2007 fusionieren Blizzard und Activision zu dem Konzern, der inzwischen als Activision Blizzard bekannt ist.
Während dieser Zeit hat Blizzard mit Activision lediglich die Fusion gemeint, denn die typischen Blizzard-Spiele werden immer noch in Eigenregie entwickelt und über den Medienkonzern Vivendi.
Immer wenn ich die Night Elves aus World of Warcraft sehe, muss ich an dieses Video zur World of Warcraft Release denken.
Das ist schon uralt, vielleicht hat das irgendjemand von euch auf YouTube gesehen, wo einer mit der Kamera so durch den Flur läuft und in das Zimmer reinfilmt von so einem World of Warcraft-Spieler.
Und dann sitzt der Typ halt vor seinem, wahrscheinlich ist es gestellt, wahrscheinlich ist es gestellt, da sitzt der Typ halt vor seinem World of Warcraft-Character-Selektor mit so einer halben nacken Night Elfe auf dem Monitor und ist da gerade zugange.
Und schmeißt ihn dann aus dem Zimmer raus. Alter, World of Warcraft Night Elves. Wie war das? Rule 34, wobei das ja noch in-game war.
Der Typ. Ja, das war schonmal der Anfang vom Ende.
Ah, da ist er. Hier. Er da. Das ist der Typ, der, ich hab vergessen, der hat irgendeinen Spitznamen bei diesem ganzen Belästigungsskandal bei Blizzard.
Der war wohl bekannt für, dass er Leute bekrapscht. Und das hier, das hier ist der Diablo-Immortal-Dude.
Hab ich gesagt. Doch.
Ah, dieses Gelaber. Dieses Gelaber immer, das ist totaler Bullshit.
Wer mal wirklich sehen will, wie man ehrlich mit der Spielerschaft kommuniziert, der muss sich beispielsweise die BlizzCon von 2005 angucken.
Da stellt sich Chef Kaplan auf die Bühne und sagt, wortwörtlich, er sagt sinngemäß, wenn ihr schlechte Heiler in der Gruppe habt, kickt sie aus der Gruppe.
Das ist so ein Ding, das ist heute ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit. Das darfst du heute nicht mehr sagen. Dann hälte dich Twitter und alle Leute zu Tode, wenn du sowas sagst.
Die hassen dich da für alle. Damals hat er gesagt, wie es ist, sagst du, ihr habt schlechte Leute, hat er irgendwie gesagt, so sinngemäß, jeder kennt das, ihr habt einen in der Gruppe, der kriegt nichts auf die Reihe, so nach dem Motto, bam, kickt die noch einfach.
Das fand ich ehrliche Kommunikation, und zwar auch zu Zeiten, wo du gemerkt hast, die spielen ihren Scheiß selber. Die spielen ihren Kram selber. Heute hast du den Eindruck, keiner von den Blizzard-Entwicklern spielt ihr Game.
Ich weiß, dass der StarCraft II-Multiplayer-Balance-Typ wohl ein ziemlich guter Random-Spieler sein muss, also Random, der spielt Klasse, also Random-Select-Klasse in StarCraft II, aber die meisten spielen ihr Scheiß-Game nicht mehr.
Sie sind Krabb teilweise noch spielen. Und immer diese Sachen mit, wir hören nicht auf die Fans, und ein halbes Jahr später erzählen wir dann auf irgendeiner Konferenz, die Fans sind das Wichtigste, und wir sind Customer-First, Gameplay-First, und wir lieben das Feedback, wir lieben unsere Fans.
Ihr liebt das Einzige, was ihr von euren Fans liebt, ist, dass die da sinnloserweise fanboyen und euch Geld in den Arsch blasen. Das ist das Einzige, warum ihr eure Fans mögt. Die Fans gehen euch mittlerweile, ich sag nicht jeder, weil es gibt sicherlich Leute, die wirklich immer noch ihr Herzblut in die Spiele stecken, aber die, die dort an den Entscheidungspositionen sitzen, denen gehen die Fans komplett am Arsch vorbei.
Und es ist einfach nur hängen geblieben für Blizzard, für Sony, für Microsoft, für egal welche, Apple, Google, was auch immer, so dieses Augen zu und Fanboy zu machen. Das ist einfach nur dumm. Das ist richtig dumm.
Man verschließt die Augen vor Scheiße, die die bauen, und redet sich alles irgendwie schön, um seine eigene Weltansicht aufrechterhalten zu können. So nach dem Motto, die können keine Scheiße bauen, weil ich bin doch Fan von denen, und weil ich Fan von denen bin, muss ich alles gut finden von denen, weil wenn ich mir jetzt eingestehen würde, dass die Scheiße gebaut haben, dann wäre ich ja umsonst 10 Jahre Fan gewesen.
Da kriegen die Leute das Gefühl, die haben komplette Persönlichkeitskrise dadurch, wenn sie mal sagen, hey, mein Lieblingsentwickler baut Scheiße.
Fanboyen ist so dumm. Es dankt dir doch auch keiner. Das muss man doch mal realistisch sehen. Es ist doch nicht so, dass du irgendwie der Fanboy des Jahres wirst und deswegen, keine Ahnung, einen Gedenkkarakter in World of Warcraft irgendwas kriegt. Das ist dir doch scheißegal. Das juckt dir doch keiner. Das dankt dir niemals jemand.
Sollte man nicht als Fan einer Serie, die sie ebenfalls kritisieren, klar, ich hab's schon oft gesagt, dass die größten Hater, die größten Fans sind, das war schon immer so.
Leute, die am meisten flamen, das sind eigentlich die, die insgeheim wollen, dass das Spiel, dass es besser wird.
Klar, die Leute haben auch meistens relativ, sagen wir mal, engstierliche oder festgefahrene Meinung, was besser bedeutet, aber die richtigen Hardcore-Fans, das sind auch gleichzeitig die größten Flamer.
Das sind aber übrigens die, über die sich normalerweise der Hersteller keine großen Gedanken machen muss, weil die spielen trotzdem, egal wie sehr sie das Spiel scheiße finden.
Über welche Spieler du dir als Hersteller Gedanken machen musst, sind die minimalen Flamer oder die gar nicht Flamer, die einfach nur sagen, gefällt mir nicht, ich geh jetzt.
Das sind die, wo du dir eigentlich wirklich Gedanken drüber machen musst, weil die größten Fans sind meistens auch die größten Hater.
... und dem Development-Team sollte sich verbessern und die angesprochenen Probleme beseitigt werden. Ein Monat später verließ Blizzard-Mitgründer Mike Morhaime das Studio und J. Alan Brack...
Da gab es ja das Gerücht, dass er unter anderem gesagt hat, Overwatch in diesem Zustand ist nicht competitive ready. Und dann hat Blizzard gesagt, Alter halt die Klappe.
Wir wollen hier Overwatch League und Big Stomps, eSport und alles machen, du kannst jetzt nicht einfach sagen, das Spiel wäre nicht ready. Und das Spiel ist nicht ready gewesen bei Release, das hat man gesehen.
Replay-Modus nach eineinhalb Jahren oder zwei Jahren Release, ein Replay-Modus, also eines der wichtigsten Sachen für Competitive-Spieler.
Ein Ranking-System, also der hatte Recht. Der ist ja auch weg mittlerweile. Der hat es nicht lang gemacht. Oh nein, Telefon. Telefon.
Ja, falsch gewettet.
Ich habe bis heute nicht verstanden, wie realitätsfern man bei Blizzard sein konnte, das nicht kommen zu sehen.
Also da sieht man, dass Blizzard, dass dort in den Entscheidungspositionen tatsächlich die Leute mittlerweile komplett detached sind von dem, was ihre Fans eigentlich wollen.
Es hätte übrigens gar keiner was gegen Diablo Immortal gab, das mag sogar ein gutes Mobile-Game werden.
Aber du kannst es nicht auf der BlizzCon als Main-Event vorstellen vor Leuten, die PC-Spieler sind, die jahrelange Blizzard-Fans sind und dann so tun, als ist es das, was die wollen.
Und wenn du dann auch noch merkst, das ist es nicht komplett. Also du hast ja gesehen, der war wirklich überrascht, dass die Leute das nicht feiern.
Also entweder sind die mittlerweile schon in solchen Illusionen im Kopf, dass die Leute pauschal einfach alles feiern, was sie vorstellen, egal was.
Ich weiß auch nicht. Einfach falsch vorgestellt. Ja, die hätten zum Beispiel, was die hätten machen müssen, es hätten 30 Sekunden länger gereicht.
30 Sekunden hätten gereicht. Die hätten Diablo Immortal vorstellen müssen und dann hätten sie den Apple-Move machen müssen.
Ach übrigens, bevor ich gehe, ich habe da noch einen Trailer für euch. Und dann rausgehen und Diablo 4 Trailer zeigen.
Es hätte sogar einen Trailer sein können, wie es Bethesda für das neue Elder Scrolls gemacht hat.
Nicht sagen, das Video, das Main Theme auf dem Klavier gespielt, 30 Sekunden und vorbei.
Das wäre das Einzige, das hätten die das gemacht. Es hätte keine Haare nach Immortal gekreht.
...einen schwachen Start hinlegte und die Stimmung eher verhalten war, stellte Diablo Immortal in vielen Köpfen den Zeitpunkt dar, an dem der Ruf Blizzards zum ersten Mal dramatisch wankte.
Der Titel sollte zudem für mobile Geräte erscheinen. Im Dezember fügte Blizzard seinem Sarg einen weiteren Nagel hinzu, als sie praktisch über Nacht die Profi-Szene von Heroes of the Storm observierten.
Selbst Pro-Gamer, Teams und Manager fuhren zum gleichen Zeitpunkt wie alle anderen Spieler, dass das Development-Team des Titels drastisch gekappt und die eSports-Szene nicht mehr unterstützt würde.
Damit wurden Karrieren praktisch über Nacht beendet.
Und vorher noch gesagt, eigene Liga und voll committed. Das ist auch so ein Ding, was mir eigentlich in allen Bereichen, wo es irgendwie um Stomps und Geld geht, so auf den Sack geht.
Die sagen alle immer, wir sind voll committed auf, also nehmen wir mal das Beispiel hier, wir sind komplett committed, Heroes of the Storm, eSport, jawoll, neue Liga, voll committed, voll committed.
Da werden die Leute gefragt, und wie sehen eure Pläne aus? Es wird größer, es wird noch besser, wir werden noch ein bisschen voll committed, eSport. Und einen Tag später, auch übrigens wieder eingestellt.
Das ist wirklich was, das geht mir schon mega auf den Sack in vielen Bereichen, sodass sie sich komplett überschlagen, so nachnehmen und jawoll wir stehen voll dahinter, voll dahinter, voll dahinter.
Überlegt euch mal, sogar Sony hat 5 Jahre oder so am Stück erzählt, wir stehen voll hinter der Playstation Vita, wir zeigen aber keine Games.
Übrigens Leute, wir stehen voll hinter der Playstation Vita. Ah ok, wir haben wieder keine Games. Wir stehen voll hinter der Playstation Vita, haben wir schon erzählt, dass wir voll hinter der Playstation Vita stehen.
Ah übrigens, jetzt ist vorbei, Playstation Vita ist weg.
Gut, Google Stadia ist auch so ein Ding.
Ach, deswegen lohnt es sich nicht zu fanboyen, weil du, das dankt dir keiner, du wirst eher noch mehr verarscht.
Und es ist besser, du fanboyst nicht so extrem, weil dann hast du zumindest noch die Chance, weil oftmals zeichnet sich sowas ja schon ab, wenn du es sehen willst im Vorfeld.
Dann hast du wenigstens die Chance sowas noch zu erkennen, als wenn du blind fanboyst.
Das Jahr 2019. Oh nein, Mitch Chung. Das war auch, das war echt wieder so ein Ding.
Blizzard mit einem langen Twitter-Post des Angestellten Julien Murillo Cuella, indem er sich über Belästigungen und rassistische Äußerungen im Hearthstone eSports Team beschwerte.
Der im Jahr 2016 geschehene Zwischenfall wurde von Julien zum HR-Team des Konzerns getragen, wo man ihm mitteilte, dass er kein Teamplayer sei und es schwierig sei mit ihm zu arbeiten.
Wenig später traf Bobby- Ja, es ist schwierig mit einem zu arbeiten, der auch mal was sagt als Ja und Amen.
Das geht ja gar nicht. Und er hört das bestimmt nicht gerne.
In einem Atemzug mit das Activision Blizzard- Also ich glaube, die einzige Antwort, die Bobby zulässt, ist Ja, genau, so machen wir das. Und wie kann ich hier noch tiefer in den Arsch kriechen?
Das ist wahrscheinlich die einzige Antwort, die dort erlaubt ist.
... im Jahr 2018 zwar Rekordgewinne einfuhr, trotzdem aber 800 Mitarbeiter- Warcraft 3 ist das beste Game oder eines der besten Games, gebe ich dir voll und ganz recht.
Trotzdem ist Reforged verkackt und das Blizzard, was Warcraft 3 gemacht hat, das hat nichts mehr mit dem zu tun, was heute am Start ist.
Die haben mit Warcraft 3 ein Spiel gemacht, was sie selber spielen wollten. Das merkst du an allen Ecken und Enden.
... Bereichen entlassen würden. Entwicklerteams wurden zwar nicht angetastet, doch die IT, eSports und Community- Bereiche von Blizzard besaßen mit einem Mal kaum noch Mitarbeiter.
In der Jahresmitte nahm daraufhin ein weiteres Gründungsmitglied seinen Hut. Frank Pearce verließ die Firma nach fast 30 Jahren.
Frank zeichnete sich durch seine Rolle als Executive Producer für Warcraft 3 und alle WoW Erweiterungen bis einschließlich Mists of Pandaria aus.
Also im Prinzip, alles was noch halbwegs okay war danach...
Vor dem Hintergrund der Unruhen in Hongkong, der Hearthstone-Pro-Spieler Chang En-Way für ein Jahr gesperrt wurde...
Übrigens, was an der Stelle immer vergessen wird.
Es wurde nicht nur der Hearthstone-Spieler gebannt, es wurden die Caster, die zufälligerweise dieses Turnier gecastet haben, auch gefeuert.
Die Caster, die können da nun wirklich nichts für, die haben sich sogar, ich weiß nicht ob ihr das damals gesehen habt, die haben sich hinter dem Tisch versteckt, die Caster.
Sie wollten nicht im Bild sein, weil die wahrscheinlich wussten, was das für sie bedeutet.
Die Caster wollten nicht im Bild sein und die haben die Caster rausgeschmissen, weil die im Bild waren, also die Kommentatoren von diesem Stream, haben die rausgeschmissen, als der Typ was erzählt hat zu Hongkong.
...began der öffentliche Druck auf Blizzard zu wachsen.
Der unter dem Nickname Blitzchang bekannte Spieler sprach sich während eines Interviews...
Der eine Caster lacht aber auch, jemand bleibt ihm nicht anders übrig.
Ist das ein Grund ihn zu kicken? Guck mal, die verstecken sich, die verstecken sich.
Die verstecken sich, das ist das, was ich meine.
...aus, woraufhin selbst die taiwanesischen Kommentatoren gefeuert wurden, die während dieses Moments anwesend waren.
Wichtig, Blitzchang brach explizit eine der Regeln des Turniers.
Das stimmt.
Das Timing und der politische Hintergrund waren...
Es gibt aber genug Gegenbeispiele.
Es gibt aber genug Gegenbeispiele, das hat man sich jetzt einfach rausgepickt.
Nur mal ein Beispiel, nur mal ein Beispiel.
Okay, es gibt eine Regel und das ist bei der Overwatch League, das ist bei mehr oder weniger allen Turnieren so, dass du keine politischen Statements machen sollst.
Aber jetzt mal ernsthaft, jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Diese Regel wird nur durchgesetzt, wenn es in das jeweilige Geld-Business-Modell reinpasst.
Wenn du einen Stream machst, wo viele Chinesen zugucken und einer sagt, was über Hongkong, natürlich wird der rausgeschmissen.
Machst du einen internationalen Stream und einer sagt, was weiß ich, Pride, Black Lives Matters, Regenbogenfahne, was auch immer, was ja auch ein Statement ist, das ist vollkommen okay.
Warum?
Weil es im aktuellen Zeitgeist dort passt und Hongkong, so im aktuellen Zeitgeist von China, nicht passt.
Es geht überhaupt nicht irgendwie um die persönliche Ansichten von Blizzard oder nicht.
Blizzard scheißt auf Hongkong, Blizzard scheißt auf Black Lives Matters, Pride oder sonst was.
Die machen einfach das, was für sie Geld bringt.
Und wenn es im Westen Geld bringt, Regenbogenfahne zu machen, ich mache keine Aussage, was ich da persönlich von, für oder widerhalte.
Wenn es im Westen eben gut ankommt, Pride und Black Lives Matters zu machen, dann machen die Unternehmen das.
Wenn es in China schlecht ankommt, was zu Hongkong zu sagen, dann wird es eben nicht gemacht.
Denen geht es rein ums Geld, um persönliche Interessen. Also nicht persönlich, sondern um rein wirtschaftliche persönliche Interessen.
Die Message hinter irgendwas sagen, geht denen allen so am Arsch vorbei, das ist denen vollkommen wurscht.
Jedoch so unglücklich, dass der Schluss nahelag, dass Blizzard seine fernöstlichen Interessen schützen wollte.
China nimmt nämlich einen großen Teil des Gaming Marktes ein.
Das Ergebnis waren Proteste vor der BlizzCon, die Einschaltung von Menschenrechtsorganisationen und sogar ein parteiübergreifender Brief.
Da haben sie richtig Kacke. Die Sperre Blitzchanks rückgängig.
Da haben sie richtig aufs Maul gekriegt oder zumindest viele Shitstorms abbekommen.
Die Features von Warcraft 3 Reforged klangen zunächst hervorragend.
Neu eingesprochene Dialoge, HD-Grafik samt neuer Modelle und ein verbessertes Interface.
Der Trailer auf der BlizzCon 2018 machte Lust auf mehr.
Was allerdings im Jahr 2020 auf den Markt kam, hatte damit nicht mehr viel gemein.
Die neuen Sprecher wurden gestrichen und die Umgebungsgrafik konnte mit den Trailern nicht mithalten.
Am härtesten traf es jedoch Langzeitfans, die mit einem Mal keine Clans mehr nutzen oder offline spielen durften.
Features, die im alten Warcraft 3 noch enthalten waren.
In der Endnutzervereinbarung sicherte sich Blizzard außerdem die Rechte an allen Mods für Warcraft 3 Reforged.
Um dem Ganzen die Krone aufzusetzen, nahm Reforged in den Spielebibliotheken automatisch den Platz des Originals ein.
Wer das alte Warcraft 3 spielen wollte, musste also wohl oder will eine Original-CD kaufen.
Du kannst halt die neue Grafik komplett vergessen für Warcraft 3.
Ich bin kein Warcraft 3-Multiplayer-Spieler, ja.
Aber ich hab was von vielen Warcraft 3-Multiplayer-Spielern schon gehört,
dass du die neue Grafik im Multiplayer nicht spielen kannst, weil du nicht mehr erkennst, was welche einer ist.
Die Situation wurde so dramatisch, dass der damalige Präsident J. Alan Bragg sich sogar förmlich bei der Spielerschaft entschuldigte.
In einem Bloomberg-Bericht aus dem Jahr 2021 bestätigten sich schließlich die Sorgen der Spieler.
Der katastrophale Zustand von Reforged entstand durch die Handlung...
Warum trennt er da Chemtrails?
Wobei, Chemtrails, das schreibt man doch anders.
Ich glaube, da trennt er nichts.
Das war was anderes.
...sondern auch das Budget des Titels drastisch kürzten.
Das geschah auch nicht zum ersten Mal.
Mitte des Jahres meldete sich ein Hearthstone-Spieler zu Wort,
dessen Frau im Rahmen der Entlassung von 800 Blizzard-Angestellten im Vorjahr auf Jobsuche war.
Als herauskam, dass seine Frau auf Twitter das Unternehmen kritisierte,
wurde er nicht mehr zu Hearthstone-Turnieren eingeladen.
Stimmt, das habe ich auch vergessen, das war ja auch so ein Ding.
Ja, ja, auch geil, oder?
Das, da kann ich mich auch noch dran erinnern.
Nach einigen gegenseitigen Anschuldigungen wurde der Spieler aber von der schwarzen Liste entfernt
und darf jetzt wieder an den offiziellen Turnieren teilnehmen.
Besonders bitter, zur gleichen Zeit schrieb Blizzard 2000 neue Jobs aus.
Die Entlassung aus dem Vorjahr schien nun besonders willkürlich und ungerechtfertigt.
Gegen Ende des Jahres begannen Blizzard-Mitarbeiter in anonymen Gruppen,
ihr Gehalt zu vergleichen und stellen dabei enorme Unterschiede fest.
Oh nein, da ist er! Gehaltsvergleich ist immer gut.
Da ist er! Da begrabt's schon.
Er hat immer viel übrig, hä?
Ja gut, das ist jetzt all aktuell. Das ja begann nicht gut für Blizzard. Das, das, das kennen wir alle.
Mit Francis Townsend heuerte das Unternehmen eine berüchtigte Bush-Ära-Politikerin an,
die zu ihrer Zeit de facto als das Gesicht im Kampf gegen den Terror fungierte
und Handlungen wie Waterboarding und Schlafentzug als unbedingt nötig verteidigte.
In ihrer Rolle als Chief Compliance Officer soll sie jetzt bei dem Konzern dafür sorgen,
dass die Spiele Blizzards die Regularien verschiedener Länder einhalten.
Townsend machte zuletzt von sich reden, als sie im Zuge der Anklagen Artikel veröffentlichte,
die Whistleblower als Gefahr für ein Unternehmen bezeichneten.
Im April des Jahres 2021 nahm Jeff Kaplan seinen Hut, der für fast 20 Jahre bei Blizzard arbeitete
und vor allem für seinen Einsatz im Bereich des Overwatch-Franchise berühmt wurde.
Fast alle alten Gesichter wurden inzwischen durch neue Manager ersetzt.
Im Juli dieses Jahres war es schließlich soweit.
PPH, Jeff Kaplan. Ich hoffe, der landet woanders und kriegt wieder was Gescheites auf die Reihe.
Es gab bekannt, dass es im Zuge einer zwei Jahre andauernden Ermittlung Klage gegen Activision Blizzard erhebt.
Die Anschuldigung, sexuelle Belästigung und Diskriminierung.
Die Klage enthält anonyme Berichte, denen zufolge Mitarbeiter sich bei Blizzard
ständigen sexuellen Belästigungen, körperlichen Zudringlichkeiten und unfairen Beförderungspraktiken ausgeliefert sehen.
Der ehemalige Creative Director Alex Afraziabi und Präsident J. Alan Bragg werden in dem Dokument explizit genannt.
Bragg, weil er die Belästigungskultur gewürdelt und ihr keinen Einhalt geboten hatte,
und Afraziabi, weil er mehrere Frauen sexuell belästigt haben soll.
Im Zuge der Ermittlungen kommt auch ans Licht, dass der Weggang Afraziabis aus dem Jahr 2020
wegen seines Verhaltens gegenüber Mitarbeitern erfolgte.
Die aggressive Antwort des Konzerns, der die Anschuldigung als widerlich und haltlos bezeichnet.
Ja, das ist übrigens auch so eine Taktik, die überall immer gefahren wird.
Es gibt eine Anschuldigung, von der man weiß, dass sie stimmt.
Es wird immer erstmal gesagt, nein, wir weisen das von uns, kann nicht sein.
Dann wird es wirklich schwer gemacht, dass man dahinter kommt.
Und umso weiter das rauskommt, der nächste Schritt ist dann, wie?
Das ist wirklich passiert, das verurteile ich ja zutiefst.
Dann sagen dann irgendwelche Stonksleute, ja, da kann ich doch nichts für.
Das ist nie bis zu mir durchgedrungen.
Dann feuern sie irgendwelche Untergebenen so nach dem Motto, die waren dafür verantwortlich,
ich nicht, bis dann irgendwie ganz am Ende mal rauskommt, doch, warst du auch.
Das ist ja so eine allgemeine Taktik, egal wo du hinguckst.
Es wird erstmal abgestritten, dann werden irgendwelche Bauern geopfert.
Und ja, wenn es dann gar so erdrückend ist, tritt mal irgendwo einer zurück.
Na klar, na klar.
Bobby denkt sich, okay, ich muss jetzt irgendwas sagen, was die Leute beruhigt
und dass der Stonkskurs nicht noch weiter runtergeht.
Der hat doch nicht im Ernst wirklich vor, da irgendwas dagegen zu unternehmen.
Der macht das, was die ganze, diesen ganzen Shitstorm am schnellsten beendet.
Wird es dem jetzt irgendwie um die Sache an sich gehen?
Das wiederum führte dazu, dass Investoren eine Sammelklage einreichten,
in der sie darauf hinwiesen, dass sie nicht in das Unternehmen investiert hätten,
wenn sie von seinen internen Problemen gewusst hätten.
Moment, da kann man klagen dagegen?
Ich dachte, das ist Risiko, wenn man investiert, dass man was nicht weiß.
Ach, der, guck mal, der ist noch da, der Diablo Immortal.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Das haben sie gut zusammengepasst.
Wie gesagt, das ist vorher schon scheiße gelaufen,
aber in den letzten Jahren war es gar nicht mehr zu übersehen.
Oh Mann.
Ja, was gucken wir sonst noch an?
Windows 11 is it nice?
Also nach allem, was ich gesehen habe, nein.
Es nervt mich an einigen Stellen.
Vor allem, dass man das hier wohl nicht mehr ausschalten kann,
dieses Zusammenfassen von Fenstern und sowas.
Richtig nervig.
Overwatch 2 wird nix gescheites, kann ich mir auch nicht vorstellen.
Ich meine, Overwatch League, hat jemand von euch
jemals wieder Overwatch League geschaut, seit das von Twitch weg ist?
Ich hab ja selbst schon eine Weile nicht mehr geschaut, als noch auf Twitch war.
Ab und zu mal reingeguckt, weil ich selbst nicht mehr gespielt habe.
Aber seit es auf YouTube ist, ich habe nicht ein Spiel geguckt,
weder Hearthstone noch Overwatch, nichts.
Oh nein.
Habt ihr eigentlich gesehen, Microsoft hat ein neues Feature in Paint eingeführt.
Ist das denn der Wahnsinn?
Passt mal auf, guckt mal da.
Ein neues Feature in Paint.
Man hat einen neuen Pinsel.
Unglaublich.
Da ist Windows 11 jetzt aber gerettet.
Also ich glaube, jetzt können wir uns wirklich nicht mehr für Windows 11 wünschen.
Jetzt gibt es noch einen Pinsel für Paint.
Das hat Paint gebraucht.
Vor allem der Witz ist halt, so was bauen Hobby-Entwickler wahrscheinlich in 2-3 Tagen ein.
Überhaupt kein Ding.
Also gut, beim Paint Source Code bin ich mir da nicht so sicher.
Da ist wahrscheinlich höchstgradig Paint-Champig, aber ja.
Übrigens, habt ihr die News gelesen, dass OnlyFans kein Hardcore-Sexual-Content mehr erlauben will?
Wo ich mich also frage, ist das nicht die einzige Daseinsberechtigung von OnlyFans gegenüber, sagen wir mal,
Patreon oder anderen Support-Seiten?
Ich meine, ich weiß, dass OnlyFans in letzter Zeit versucht, ein bisschen Richtung Fitness-Trainer-Geschichten und so was zu gehen.
Aber mal ehrlich, 90% von OnlyFans oder der einzige...
Wie habe ich denn gesagt?
Die Daseinsberechtigung von OnlyFans ist doch, dass die Leute sich Nackt-Fotos von ihren beliebten Streamern angucken können.
Oder irgendwelche Dildo-Videos oder was auch immer.
Das ist doch die einzige Daseinsberechtigung von OnlyFans.
Wenn OnlyFans das nicht mehr erlaubt, ist OnlyFans einfach weg vom Fenster.
Aber bei Tumblr hast du das auch gesehen.
Kein Porn mehr erlaubt, Tumblr weg.
Gut, gibt's noch, interessiert bloß kein Mensch mehr.
Ja, und OnlyFans hat jetzt eine App gelauncht.
Family-Friendly, safe for work.
Guckt mal, wie beliebt diese OnlyFans-App ist.
Er fährt sich rum.
Das ist ja der absolute Hit geworden, OnlyFans-TV.
Ja, genau, nackt sein darfst du noch, aber du darfst halt keine Hardcore-Sachen mehr machen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, wegen nacktem oder halbnacktem erotischen Cosplay-Bildern,
gibt doch keiner der Fanboys Geld auf OnlyFans aus.
Ich mein, die Leute gehen auf OnlyFans, weil sie da ihre Lieblings-Content-Kreator-Innen
sich halt nackig beeinschlägigen Handlungen zugucken wollen.
Hast du schon für das Jugendwort abgestimmt?
Ja, cringe, cringe ist mein Jugendwort 2021.
Ja, gut, verstehe ich, verstehe nicht.
Gucken wir mal weiter.
Ich wusste nie, wie oft ich Files renamen wollte bis zu Windows 11.
Die Feature ist aktuell hinter einem extra Klick geheim.
Also klickst du jetzt auf etwas, gehst runter, zeigst mehr Optionen, dann wieder runter, um zu renamen.
Das ist schrecklich.
Klar, es könnte nur extra sein.
Aber in diesem Video konnte ich es nicht suchen, weil die Suchebar-
Das war zu High-IQ für mich jetzt.
... randomly stoppt arbeiten und spielte eine dieser neuen Error-Sounds jedes Mal, die ich probierte.
Das ist wahrscheinlich das größte Problem mit Windows 11, das ich bisher erlebt habe.
Aber es ist wirklich angenehm.
Glaub mir, du nimmst diese Suchebar für gratis, bis sie weg ist.
Ich wusste nie, wie oft ich Files renamen wollte bis zu Windows 11.
Die Feature ist-
Alter, das geht mir auf den Sack.
Da habe ich auch im Stream schon richtig mich darüber aufgeregt, dass man jetzt ein Kontextmenü hat und ein Unterkontextmenü.
Warum? Was ist Microsoft? Was ist los mit Microsoft?
Guck mal, Kontextmenü und jetzt musst du ins Unterkontextmenü gehen, um das aufzumachen.
Das ist so- Warum? Bitte Microsoft, warum brauchen wir ein neues Kontextmenü und ein altes Kontextmenü?
F2, ich glaube, es geht immer noch.
Aber warum? Was ist die Daseinsberechtigung davon schon wieder?
Das ist so schlecht.
Das ist so- Das ist so painstamp. Warum macht man das denn?
The feature is currently hidden away behind an extra click.
So right now you click on something, go down to show more options, then down again to rename.
This is horrible.
Ja.
Sure, it might only be an extra click and mouse movement every time.
But this quickly adds up when you're renaming-
Ganz oben ist doch noch ein icon für umbenennen?
Das ist ausschneiden? Kopieren? Ist das hier oben benennen?
Das probieren wir jetzt aus, Leute.
Ich habe hier eine Windows 10 Installation.
Das probieren wir jetzt aus.
Aber dann, eine Sache sieht man schon mal da dran.
Selbst wenn das da oben- Es gibt immer noch zwei Systemsteuerungen.
Selbst wenn das da oben das macht, was wir denken jetzt, scheint das icon nicht gut genug gewesen zu sein, dass er das erkannt hat.
Also sprich, ähm, zumindest das icon ist nicht glücklich gewählt, wenn man das nicht erkennt.
Auch Windows 10, äh, 11.
Qtweep 93, wir sind am Start.
Qtweep 93.
Okay, rename.
Tatsächlich.
Okay, das muss man wissen.
Ich hätte es auch nicht- Ohne Mist, ich hätte es nicht gefunden, dass das rename ist.
Jetzt wo ihr mir das gesagt habt, okay, hätte ich nicht gesehen.
Hätte ich nicht- Hätte ich nicht- Hätte ich nicht erkannt.
Ascii sagt, warum denn überhaupt die Symbole, wenn der Rest Text ist?
Microsoft ist Meister darin, inkonsistente UIs zu machen.
Ja, geht mir auch richtig auf den Sack.
Ich will das entgroupt haben.
Ja, genau.
Das, das, das wird mich richtig abwarten.
Logo, danke fürs Up.
Lego auch, danke fürs Up, habe ich gesehen.
Schuppenflaume auch, hier, danke fürs Up.
Flofus, Captain Peng, alle am Start wieder.
So wie so Zeit für Linux, ja, ich predigte auch, ne.
Nächstes Jahr 2022 wird es das Jahr des Linux Desktop.
Nein, das wird nicht passieren.
Das wird nicht passieren.
Dafür funktioniert einfach zu wenig.
Und die 0815 User sind immer noch überfordert, was noch nicht besser werden wird.
Ja, ganz ehrlich.
Ganz ehrlich.
Ja, der Unterschied bei dem 0815 User zwischen Windows und Linux ist, erstens, Windows ist
vorinstalliert, die Leute haben sich die letzten Jahre daran gewöhnt.
Das heißt, sie können damit schon mal grob umgehen.
Sie wissen, sie können sich irgendeine Hardware kaufen, anstöpseln, den Treiber nach vorn ins
CDS funktionieren.
Sie wissen, sie können ihre Bildbearbeitung mit Programm XY machen.
Sie wissen, das funktioniert.
Sie können, was weiß ich, sucht euch irgendeinen xp-liebigen Anwendungsfall raus, wo du dir
halt sagen kannst, okay, das geht sicherlich irgendwie auch unter Linux oder auch gar
nicht, aber nicht in irgendeiner Art und Weise handlebar nach einem Umstieg von dem normalen
User.
Deswegen habe ich ja auch aufgehört, Leute bekehren zu wollen, weil die Sache ist, die
Leute, die umsteigen von Windows auf Linux, die gehen immer damit ran und sagen, hey,
das ist ja eigentlich wie Windows, bloß ein bisschen anders.
Das stimmt nicht.
Es ist nicht wie Windows.
Es ist komplett anders.
Deswegen finde ich auch alle Distributionen, die versuchen auszusehen wie Windows kontraproduktiv.
Das muss nicht aussehen wie Windows.
Das sollte auch gar nicht aussehen wie Windows.
Dass die Leute nicht auf die Idee kommen, es ist wie Windows, weil es ist nicht wie
Windows.
Und eines der schlimmsten Sachen, was Windows geschafft hat, ist, dass man das Terminal
nicht mag.
Man kann eben dieses standardbeschissene Windows-CMD nicht mit einem ordentlichen Linux-Terminal
mit einer ordentlichen Shell vergleichen.
Das sind einfach welchen Unterschied.
Leider sind die Leute so geschockt von CMD und Batch, dass sie eine komplette Abneigung
haben gegen Fenster mit schwarzem Hintergrund und weißer Schrift und das als irgendwas
mittelalterliches darstellen.
Dabei ist Linux-Commando-Zeile eigentlich das Beste, was du machen kannst unter dem Betriebssystem.
Ja, das neue Terminal laden sich die Leute nicht runter, aber zum Glück ist mit Windows
11 dabei.
Aber selbst das, die Leute sind so trainiert, die haben das Terminal zu hassen gelernt und
das wirst du bei den Usern nicht mehr rauskriegen.
PrimeSky sagt, wenn Linux mal so weit ist, dass ich einfach alle Games zocken kann, ohne
Probleme wechsle ich zu Linux.
Ja, alle Games würde ja auch automatisch bedeuten, alle andere Windows-Programme funktionieren,
aber das wird so nicht passieren.
Es ist die letzten Jahre über schon deutlich besser geworden, aber du hast immer noch Probleme.
Das ist ja auch ehrlich gesagt die größte Hoffnung, die ich an Steam Deck habe.
Nicht etwa, dass das eintreten wird, was Valve sagt, dass du alles irgendwie spielen können
wirst, dass sie schwach sind, aber ich hoffe, es wird dazu beitragen, dass noch mehr Spiele
laufen unter Linux und Spiele, die jetzt schon laufen, noch besser laufen unter Linux.
Wo sind wir jetzt stehen geblieben?
Ich vergesse.
Das ist übrigens ein guter Punkt.
Linux ist zu vielfältig für die breite Masse.
Ja, da ist tatsächlich was dran.
Das ist gleichzeitig Vorteil und Nachteil von Linux.
Wisst ihr, warum so viele Leute Mac OS als easy ansehen?
Weil unter Mac OS hast du standardmäßig für die meisten Sachen den Apple-Blessed-Gesegneten-Apple-Way
was zu machen und was anderes gibt es schlicht und ergreifend nicht.
Und wenn es was anderes gibt, dann baut Apple dafür, dass man das nicht verwenden will.
Es gibt so quasi diesen abgesegneten Apple-Weg unter Mac OS und iOS.
So hast du die Sachen zu machen.
Das heißt, es ist quasi jeder Mac auf der Welt irgendwie einheitlich.
Da ist ja bei Windows mehr Wildwuchs drin.
Aber von Linux ganz zu schweigen.
Linux auf dem Desktop hat zwei Probleme.
Die Hardware ist unterschiedlich und das Betriebssystem an sich ist noch unterschiedlich zusammengestellt.
Bei Mac hast du den einfachsten Fall.
Betriebssystem und Hardware ist einheitlich.
Bei Windows hast du Betriebssystem ist halbwegs einheitlich, Hardware ist unterschiedlich
und bei Linux auf dem Desktop hast du Hardware ist total random
und Betriebssystem ist total random.
Das stimmt tatsächlich.
Das ist zu gemixt für den Mainstream.
Ja, das laggt.
Das laggt, aber das schiebe ich auf Debug-Bild.
Das stimmt, das schiebe ich auf Debug-Bild.
Ja, es könnte aber auch sein, dass es nicht an dem Debug-Bild liegt, sondern dadurch, dass es touch-friendlier sein soll.
Ich meine, dein Gehirn schiebt das Lack aus.
Das macht das nur, indem du meine Aktionen mehr schiebst.
Wiederhole ich.
Das ist die K264-Decoding-Linux im Browser. Es geht mittlerweile unter bestimmten Bedingungen auch noch nicht für alle Codecs,
aber das hat fünf Jahre gedauert im Vergleich zu anderen Betriebssystemen.
Die einzige Plattform, wo ihr Negative Latency bekommt, ist Stadia, wisst ihr doch.
Da hast du die Gegner schon gekillt, bevor du abgeballert hast in dem Spiel.
Aber das scheint jetzt fix zu sein.
Ich würde dir nicht empfehlen, wenn du Windows 11 upgraden würdest, wenn du Windows für deine Arbeit benutzt.
Es hat mich nicht gestoppt, aber es ist weniger einfach und es ist schneller zu benutzen,
sogar wenn es um die Muscle-Memory verwendet wurde in meinen Jahren mit Windows 10.
Ich erinnere mich, dass das noch ein Beta ist.
Das war's für heute.
Ich habe es nicht erwartet, dass es perfekt wird.
Aber ich versuche jetzt, alles zu finden, was ich an Windows 11 mag.
Es macht mich wundern, warum sie sich daran interessieren.
Das ist wohl wahr, ja. Es gibt ein paar coole Sachen, zum Beispiel, dass sie wohl standardmäßig weniger Sachen im Hintergrund laufen lassen wollen.
Aber das ist alles so minimal.
Achso, übrigens, ich habe meine persönliche Theorie, warum es Windows 11 gibt.
Ich vermute mal, das liegt an irgendwelchen Support-Verträgen.
Genauso wie damals mit Windows Vista.
Eine Windows-Version, die sie quasi nur rein aus Support-Vertragsgründen herausgebracht haben,
weil sie eben zugesichert haben, es gibt eine neue Windows-Version.
Ich denke auch, dass das irgendwas mit BWL, Stonks, Support, Lizenz-Vertragsgründen zu tun hat, warum es ein Windows 11 gibt.
Weil Feature-mäßig ergibt es keinen Sinn.
Aber ich habe eine Option gefunden, es in der Sicherheitssektion in meinem Bios zu ermöglichen, so wie hier.
Aber das Video, das ich mit meinem 350-Jahre-Card mitgebracht habe,
und jetzt versuche ich, meine Geldwerte auszuweichen.
Ich habe eine Serie von Benchmarken auf Windows 10 verwendet, dann sofort auf 11 und wieder verwendet,
und die Resultate waren sicherlich langweilig, mit nur einem 1-2% Performance-Drop im Allgemeinen.
Und dieser Drop war ziemlich konsistent in jedem Test, den ich gemacht habe.
Also, obwohl mein Test nicht so stark war, kann ich sagen, dass Windows 11 ein bisschen schwerer ist als Windows 10.
Und es gab auch Benchmarks, die genau das Gegenteil gesagt haben, dass Windows 11 angeblich ein bisschen schneller wäre.
Also da würde ich jetzt mal gar nichts draus geben.
Außerdem ist das irgendein Debug-Bild, genau, oder zumindest nicht ganz so optimiert.
Ich habe also eine gewisse Unterschiede mit meinem SSD, bei dem es 13% höher war als bei Windows 10.
Mit all dem habe ich meinen PC für die Nacht geschlossen und die ganze Nacht gedacht.
Curios, um zu sehen, ob das angeblich ist, habe ich den ganzen Test-Bench wieder gestartet am nächsten Morgen.
Und dann ein zweites Mal, nach einem System-Restart, nur um sicher zu sein.
Diese frühen Morgen-Tests haben die CPU-Performance in Cinebench gezeigt,
für Gründe, die ich nicht erklären kann, aber die ich in meinen Test-Methoden verletzt habe.
Aber außerhalb davon waren die anderen Tests alle ähnlich, wie sie vorher waren,
außerhalb von meiner SSD-Speed und Benchmark, die ich jetzt sogar noch schneller dachte,
mit 128% höheren Benchmark.
Also mal diese Benchmark-Sachen außen vor gelassen.
Ja, gut, das Benchmark-Zug ist wirklich sinnlos.
Die Leute upgraden gar nicht, würde ich mal behaupten.
Die Leute kaufen sich einen neuen PC und da ist Windows 11 dabei.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass jemand wirklich sagt,
hey, Windows 11 ist neu, ich mache jetzt Instant-Upgrade.
Ich werde wahrscheinlich upgraden, aber sicherlich nicht sofort.
Oder wie sieht es mit euch aus?
Also mal angenommen, Windows 11 kommt jetzt raus.
Wann kommt denn das raus überhaupt, Windows 11?
Wann ist denn der Release?
Windows 11.
Release Date.
Ende des Jahres 2021.
Ok, sagen wir mal Dezember oder so.
Upgraded wirklich jemand, nur weil das neu ist, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Also ich werde auf jeden Fall mal die ersten eins, zwei,
äh, monthly, äh, nicht halt, nicht halt, halbjährige Updates abwarten,
bevor ich das upgrade.
Ja, das, das, das Problem war ich auch.
Ich mag das nicht.
By the way, die Runde Ecken, die gibt es einzig und allein aus dem optischen Grund.
Die gibt es, dass man sagen kann,
hier wir grenzen uns klar vom Vorgänger ab.
Irgendwie, wie hätte man Opa gesagt? Sittlichen Mehrwert hat das Ganze nicht.
Alles fühlt sich zu flotig und verbunden. Zum Beispiel ist das Start-Menü jetzt separat von der Bar am Boden und das fühlt sich falsch an.
Es fühlt sich an, als würde es in ein paar Sekunden verschwinden. Oder mein Kursor könnte sich in die Klappe schlagen.
Der Notifikations-Panel auf der rechten Seite des Schrausens ist gewechselt für, du hast es gewusst, ein anderes Fenster.
Und um jetzt zu schalten, nach dem Klicken des Start-Klicks, muss ich über dieses rechte Hand-Korner reinkommen,
anstatt es über dem Start-Klick zu sein, wo es vorher war.
Das ist das letzte F-U, bevor ich in der Nacht schlafe. Einfach, dass ich mir nicht zu viel um diese Sachen interessiere.
Das ist super offiziell, oder?
Aber was ich mag, ist, dass das Start-Menü die Flexibilität und Funktionalität reduziert hat.
Ich liebe das Windows 10 für das. Du kannst die Programme, die du wollen, benutzen.
Ja, man muss schon sagen, das Windows 10 Start-Menü war am Anfang schon ziemlicher Paint-Champ versus das Windows 7 Start-Menü.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, warum die immer so scharf drauf sind, an den Basics-Sachen immer so grundlegend was zu ändern.
Da muss man wirklich Apple mal zugute halten. Die machen natürlich auch Updates.
Und Mac OS von heute sieht anders aus als Mac OS von vor zehn Jahren.
Aber die machen das meistens zumindest immer so graduell und meistens auch nicht so komplett breaking.
Also Apple sagt nicht, hey, der Button war jetzt immer hier, jetzt machen wir den Button da unten zentriert oder sowas.
Das passiert vielleicht über fünf Betriebssystem-Updates und die Icon ändern sich mal und sowas.
Aber ansonsten machen die deutlich weichere, langsamere Anpassungen.
Wie geht's bei Razer? Das haben wir uns angekostet.
Ja.
Es wird alles wegmachen.
Übrigens, wer gefragt hat, ob es das alte System Steuerung noch gibt, ihr seht sie, es gibt sie noch.
Natürlich.
Ich hätte ja erwartet, wenn man Windows 11 macht, dann rollt man wirklich mal unten drunter auf.
Also dass man nicht fünf verschiedene Settings hat aus 20 Jahren Windows und solche Sachen.
Aber ich glaube, das wären sie nie wieder los.
Ich muss euch ja sagen, ratet mal, ratet mal, was für mich das optisch ansprechendste Windows war.
Ihr wisst, ich bin alt, ja.
7 XP ist da.
XP, ja, tatsächlich, ist XP.
XP, ich finde, XP hat, klar, kannst du aus heutiger Seite sagen, das sieht aus wie im Zirkus,
Windows XP, Windows XP sieht nicht mehr so nach Minimal, also Windows XP hat voll geklotzt und nicht gekleckert, ja.
Zum heutigen Minimal Design und möglichst viele Drop Shadows und sonst was passt Windows XP nicht mehr.
Aber ich muss echt sagen, Windows XP hatte den eigensten Look von jedem Windows
und auch den zusammenhängendsten Look von jedem Windows.
Und sie haben unter Windows XP noch nicht angefangen, alles zu ver-applifien und zu ver-touchen und sowas.
Also sprich, da hatten Windows Programme noch Optionen und Kontext Menüs,
die eben noch nicht so gut waren.
Also ich glaube, das ist das Problem mit Windows XP.
Ich glaube, das ist das Problem mit Windows XP.
Also sprich, da hatten Windows Programme noch Optionen und Kontext Menüs, die eben auch,
wenn es komplexe Programme waren, eben komplexe Einstellungen erlaubt haben
und nicht so nach dem Motto, wir schmeißen alles raus, was man nicht mit einer Hand in einem Touch Menü machen kann.
Guckt euch, vergleicht mal uraltes, popliches Outlook Express mit Windows 10 Mail.
Windows 10 Mail ist halt einfach grottenschlecht.
Selbst gegen ein uraltes Outlook Express, natürlich kannst du Outlook Express heute nicht mehr richtig verwenden,
weil du beispielsweise gar nicht mehr gescheit zu einem verschlüsselten Mailseufer connecten kannst.
Aber das ist ja nicht das, was ich sagen will.
Von den Funktionen her, von den Optionen, von den Menüs, das war ein Desktop-Programm, Outlook Express.
Windows 10 ist irgendein Möchtegern-Tablet-Programm, wo die Hälfte der Funktionen fehlen für Mail.
Glück gibt es auf Thunderbird und die machen es ehlig.
Ja, das stimmt.
By the way, es gibt natürlich immer noch Fotos, was Videos abspielen kann, dann gibt es Videos und Medien,
und dann gibt es noch Media Player, was auch noch am Start ist. Wir haben ja auch wieder 20 Jahre Windows.
Ja, das habe ich auch schon, je nach was zum Geier.
Ich werde es nicht machen.
Ich glaube, Media Center gibt es nicht mehr.
Also Browser austauschen kann es ja noch relativ einfach.
Das muss ich sagen, dass sie das mitliefern, ist mir lieber als Skype vorinstalliert.
Was übrigens witzig ist, wenn man das mal vergleicht, hier ist Settings, das ist das Windows 10 Settings und das ist das Windows 11 Settings.
Also im Prinzip hat sich da jetzt, es hat halt andere Icons, aber das ist nichts, was man nicht hätte auch unter Windows 10 machen können.
Zumal es ja nichts daran geändert hat, dass es diesen alten Control Panel Shit und sowas immer noch gibt.
Ja, sehe ich auch so. Also das hier ist viel besser als das hier.
Aber trotzdem, das ist ja im Prinzip immer noch die gleiche Technik drunter, die hätten da ohne Probleme das auch in Windows 10 machen können.
Da ist das Control Panel noch da.
Ok, Restart mal im Hintergrund, weiter kommt.
Ist das nicht Window I3? Doch, aber bestimmt immer noch UVP unten drunter.
Und selbst wenn nicht, wäre das trotzdem unter Windows 10 Problemlos möglich gewesen.
Na gut, bis wenn mir jetzt wurscht.
Wisst ihr wie das aussieht? Sieht aus wie Pringles Chips, bloß halt ein bisschen mehr gefaltet. Zumindest das hier, das hier sieht aus wie so ein Pringles Chip.
Aber der Rest, der Rest nicht.
Tatsächlich, sagt er auch.
Ich habe eh den einzig wahren Windows Hintergrund.
Also sowohl die einzig wahren Desktop-Anordnungen und den einzig wahren Windows Hintergrund.
Na ja, Klimaerwärmung ist doch ganz klar.
Outpad++ braucht keiner, einfach Visual Studio Code installiert und gut ist.
Das hat doch jetzt schon einen Flight Mode, oder?
Ja, meinetwegen, ihr könnt auch WIMP verwenden, jeder was er will.
Wobei ist alles bloat. Ich mach prinzipiell, editiere ich nur meine Text mit SET und AWK.
Alles andere ist bloated. GUI ist bloated.
Das ist bescheuert.
Also ich muss sagen, Stability-Probleme hatte ich keine, ich habe es aber geschafft Windows 11 zu crashen.
Und zwar mit WSL.
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern?
Moment, ich zeig's euch.
Bei den Clips ganz vorne, anscheinend mochten das die Leute.
Wo ist es denn?
Okay, der Crash ist anscheinend doch nicht drauf.
Kommt aber wahrscheinlich aufs Ähnliche raus.
Na ja, Windows 11 installiert man doch jetzt noch nicht, das machst du in der VM.
Nö, brauchst du auch nicht.
Ich hab Vista damals für das Media Center verwendet, im Wohnzimmer.
Was würdest du jemandem empfehlen, wenn er jetzt wegen Windows 11 auf Windows wechseln will, gar nicht einfach von Windows 10 bleiben, weil man sollte nicht davon ausgehen, dass man Linux in irgendeiner Art und Weise verwenden kann wie Windows.
Man muss sagen, ich will keinen Windows-Ersatz haben.
Wenn Windows Server ernsthaft irgendwo benutzt, ja, tatsächlich, ich kann's mir zwar nicht erklären, aber wird es.
Einzige Anwendungsberechtigung, die irgendwelche Actives-Directory-Geschichten sein.
Ja.
Dass ein Android-Emulator dabei ist, finde ich tatsächlich auch cool.
Warum ist es ridiculous, dass Windows keine Android-Apps unterstützt?
Machen sie ja teilweise.
Aber wozu braucht man bitte schön Windows, um.NET Web-Apps laufen zu lassen?
Es gibt also einfach wie unter Windows, wenn nicht einfacher. Es gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn,.NET Apps unter Windows laufen zu lassen.
Was auch immer.
Okay, ich würde sagen, das Video ist durch. Reicht.
Also manchmal hat er es ein bisschen übertrieben am Großen und Ganzen, würde ich ihm sogar zustimmen.
By the way, wenn ich hier aufgehe, Leute, dann mache ich mir was zu essen und danach schalte ich Video frei.
Stellenanzeigen. Reaction Nummer 4.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch zu bieten?
Das gucken wir uns jetzt nochmal an, weil das Thumbnail so ausgesehen hat, als weiß der Typ was er macht.
Was zum Teufel bin ich? Was bin ich denn hier sehend jetzt?
Das ist doch ein 3D Render.
Kreativität ist die Erschaffung von Dingen. Okay. Ja.
Das ist doch Verarschung, oder? Ja, das ist Verarschung.
Ja, das geht. Das geht. Chat, das funktioniert. Es gibt verschiedene Varianten.
Kennst du eine Möglichkeit, mein Bett erkennen zu lassen, wenn ich drin liege?
Ja, da gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Also du kannst einen Gewichtssensor probieren.
Irgendwie unter das Bein vom Bett. Dann gibt es solche Matten, die du unter die Matratze legen kannst, die erkennt, wenn man drauf liegt.
Dann könntest du sicherlich irgendwie detekten, also wie gesagt, es gibt viele Varianten.
Da könntest du sicherlich irgendwie detekten, wenn man sich drauf legt mit irgendeinem Erschütterungssensor zum Beispiel.
Den kannst du wahrscheinlich auch drunter klemmen, weil wenn man sich aufs Bett legt, man kann sich gar nicht so sanft aufs Bett legen, dass der Erschütterungssensor das nicht mitbekommt.
Du könntest sicherlich auch was mit einem Bewegungssensor machen. Du könntest einen Radar oder einen Schaltsensor nehmen, um zu gucken, ob was drauf liegt.
Da gibt es verdammt viele Möglichkeiten. Das einfachste dürfte aber Gewicht sein.
Da gibt es fertige Drucksensoren, die kann man drunter legen und die schließt man dann entweder.
Da gibt es so was wahrscheinlich, vermute ich mal, also bin ich mir jetzt nicht sicher, weil sowas habe ich nicht gekauft bisher. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es fertige Drucksensoren gibt mittlerweile fürs Bett, die man ins WLAN hängen kann.
Ansonsten brauchst du einen Drucksensor und machst einen Microcontroller dran. Gucken wir doch mal.
Was ist dein Lieblingsdetektion im Bett? Gucken wir doch mal.
Tatsächlich habe ich noch einen.
Das ist das erste woran ich gedacht habe.
Ja sowas geht. Das ist so eine Schiene, die legt man dann da rein.
Also es gibt einige. Amazon, ja genau, sowas kann man nehmen.
Das legt man dann da drunter, das verändert den Widerstand, wenn was drauf liegt und dann machst du einen Microcontroller dran und kannst das easy auslesen, ob das Bett belegt ist oder nicht.
Also wie ich gerade aufgestellt habe, es gibt einige Varianten.
Das ist tatsächlich die einfachste Variante, da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht, das habe ich auch schon mal gemacht.
Du pappst dir einen RFID Aufkleber neben ans Bett und legst dein Handy einfach, wenn du schlafen gehst, drauf.
Das kannst du machen.
Naja zum Beispiel, wenn du sagst, es ist nach 22 Uhr und ich lege im Bett, dann mache ich alles aus im Haus nach einer Viertelstunde oder so.
Da gibt es schon Anwendungszwecke für.
Kann man alles machen, also gibt es jede Menge Sachen.
First World Problems also, naja, wenn für dich alles First World Problems sind, was nicht zum direkten Überleben, also sprich Essen, Unterkunft, Heizung beiträgt, dann ist ja quasi unsere komplette Existenz hier fast nur noch ein gesamtes First World Problem.
Aber eins ist klar, wenn die First World ihre Problems nicht ernst nimmt, ist sie bald keine First World mehr.
Deswegen, First World Problems müssen auch ernst genommen werden.
Ok, gucken wir mal weiter.
Eine weitere Ankündigung zu machen.
Nein, tatsächlich gibt es hier kein Produkt zu kaufen, was man dann nächstes Jahr nur wieder wegschmeißen kann, weil es schon wieder eine neue Version gibt.
Ich meine, das habe ich nämlich im Thumbnail gesehen. Ich muss sagen, für selbstgebaut sieht das durchaus sehr edel aus.
Also die meisten Leute kommen da mit irgendwelchen billig zusammen gedruckten, 3D gedruckten Dingern hin.
Er macht ja wirklich eine richtige, ich würde mal sagen, Glasfront oder sowas ist das.
Intro war nicht echt, aber diese Klingel.
Warum nicht? Das ist doch ganz einfach. Guck mal, wir haben zum Beispiel uns beim Thema Internetausbau nicht, als das noch ein First World Problem für uns war, nicht genug darum gekümmert.
Schon sind wir, was Internetsachen angeht, kein First World mehr.
Also wenn sich ein First World Land nicht um seine First World Problems kümmert, werden sie irgendwann zumindest in manchen Bereichen halt nicht mehr First World sein.
Ich meine, nur weil irgendwas First World ist auf dem Entwicklungsstand heißt es ja nicht, dass wenn man nichts daran macht, dass dann in 10 Jahren immer noch First World ist.
Internet, bei uns ist der Ausbau halt, naja, weiß nicht, ob es dritte Welt ist, aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht angemessen.
Ist echt. Das heißt, das war nur die gerenderte Vorlage.
Das sieht cool aus. Das sieht cool aus, was er da gebaut hat.
Das ist ein One-Man-Hobby-Projekt.
Das ist so ordentlich. Guck dir mal da hier, 3D gedrucktes, 3D gedrucktes in die Wand steck Ding, Gehäuse, ordentliche Klemmen sogar hinten dran.
Also allein schon, dass der ordentliche Klemmen hinten dran gemacht hat, ist richtig Big Brain.
Ich nehme dafür meistens irgendwelche Kabels, die raushängen und klipps dann als zwei Vago-Klemmen zusammen.
Oder ich löte es zusammen oder ich mach dann so einen Lötverbinder-Schrumpfschlauch-Hybrid-Ding, wo du einfach das Feuerzeug drunter halten musst dran.
Aber die richtig Klemmen, das ist hier richtig, richtig big.
Und logischerweise bedeutet das lebenslange Garantie, Updates, Upgrades, Datenschutz.
Ja, das heißt aber auch, man muss sich lebenslang darum kümmern.
Weil man fast alles reparieren kann, also ist Greenwashing hier überhaupt nicht nötig.
Und Greenwashing ist ohnehin Handarbeit, denn das ist ja nicht so was wie eine Greenwashing-Maschine, oder?
Also, wie habe ich es gemacht?
Zuerst habe ich Prototypen getestet und programmiert, den Touch-Button mal ausprobiert, das Text-Display.
Also ich würde immer noch, weiß nicht wie ihr das seht, Chet, ich bevorzuge bei sowas immer noch einen richtig echten Button versus einem Touch-Button.
Das Problem ist hier nur einen richtig echten Button reinzubekommen, weil für mich sieht es so aus, als hätte er hier eine glas Scheibe drüber.
Was hat er da oben?
Splendor? Ah, das Splendor.
Entworfen, daher war die Animation am Anfang auch nahenliegend und das Ganze anschließend gebaut.
Die Materialien, die gibt es wirklich an jeder Ecke und die Werkzeuge hat fast jeder zu Hause.
Na ja, ein 3D-Drucker ist sicher ganz praktisch.
Und wenn man jemanden kennt, der einem Edelstahl professionell zuschneiden kann, ist das sicher auch ganz gut.
Und ich bin ein Sparfuchs, denn die Kosten des Projekts bleiben unter 30 Euro.
Inklusive China-Bordbestellen zurück.
Ach, ich glaube, es hat schon ein bisschen mehr gekostet, aber die alten Teile sind tatsächlich nicht.
Halt die Schnauze!
Alle, die in diesem Kanal schon etwas länger folgen, kennen vermutlich mein Smart Home Video aus 2020.
Aber weil da einiges bereits schon etwas eingestaubt ist, kommt da halt ein großes Update-Video.
Vielleicht ist es auch schon da.
Auf jeden Fall Newsletter und Abo nicht vergessen.
Jedenfalls habe ich schon länger...
Muss ich mal gucken, ist es da?
Ist es da?
Wo ist der Unterschied?
Ach, das ist die englische Variante.
Ist doch nicht da.
Selbstgebaute Türklingel in Betrieb und Freunde und Familie finden sowas dann natürlich erstmal ganz cool.
Klar, Mama sagt sowieso, dass sie nicht mehr in der Familie mitbekommen werden.
Aber ja, das ist natürlich ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen.
Aber ja, selbstgebaute Türklingel in Betrieb und Freunde und Familie finden sowas dann natürlich erstmal ganz cool.
Klar, Mama sagt sowieso, das hast du echt super gemacht.
Aber...
Nee, meine wird dazu sagen, wozu braucht man dann sowas?
Schön und vielleicht auch günstiger als 500 Euro.
Und naja, ohne dass jedes Bild auf irgendeinem Amazon-Server gespeichert wird.
Man kann das ganze Haus steuern und noch sehen, wer vor der Tür steht.
Klar, aber dann müssen wir schon selber ran.
Ja gut, das ist das Problem an der ESP-Cam.
Mit halbwegs ordentlicher Auflösung ist da nicht mit viel FPS.
Denn wenn du genauso ein Smart-Home-Fan wie ich bist, dann weißt du vermutlich schon,
dass die scheinbar modernen Hersteller und Elektro-Installateure auch nur mit Wasser kochen.
Und nicht selten geschlossene Systeme wie dieses Jira-System einbauen.
Jira!
Weil die Einbindung in Open-Source-Software wie Home Assistant da so ziemlich unmöglich ist.
Ich meine, warum bauen selbst Experten die Anzeige der Videoklingel direkt neben ein separates Tablet,
auf dem dann alles...
Ja, weil sich der Scheiß nicht richtig integrieren lässt.
...so irgendwie integriert ist.
Ich meine, Leute, das geht echt besser.
Man muss kein Genie sein, um das Klingel-Video mit Home Assistant und Motion Eye
auf ein billiges Tablet zu integrieren.
Aber irgendwas Krasses muss man für so einen Haufen Geld doch bekommen.
Ich meine, ich weiß es nicht.
Klett mich auf.
Vielleicht ist es Gesichtserkennung oder sowas.
Obwohl, die habe ich ja auch.
Naja, es ist vor allem mal eine Sache, wenn du eine ordentliche Gegensprechanlage
und Tür-Klingel hast mit eigener Verkabelung, die geht halt nicht einfach kaputt.
Nur weil das WLAN weg ist oder irgendwie was...
mal einen Kurzschluss irgendwo gegeben oder sonst wie.
Also ich würde schon sagen, dass die prinzipiell robuster sind als sowas selbstgestricktes,
wenn die jetzt die passende Technik drumherum hat.
Dafür hast du hier den Vorteil, dass du es halt komplett bauen kannst, wie du willst.
Genug markiert.
Wie baut man sich denn so ein Ding Dong selber?
Da mein erstes Design doch etwas speziell ist, habe ich das Design etwas massentauglicher gestaltet.
Der Rahmen ist aus Edelstahl.
Ich hätte halt gerne einen echten Backen.
Hier sieht man mal die Maß und die Form.
Und darin eingefasst liegt eine 13 x 18 cm Bilderrahmen-Glasscheibe.
Und die gibt es ja so gut wie in jedem Laden.
Dahinter ist bedruckte Schaufensterfolie.
Die kann man sich drucken lassen, wie man gerade lustig ist.
Zum Beispiel für Filmfans.
Ich befürchte, ich kann die Tür nicht öffnen, Dave.
Oder das Modell Finde Waldo.
Was? Was? Wo ist die? Das finde ich ja geil.
Wo ist denn die Klingel?
Das ist ja fies.
Finde Waldo und du findest die Klingel.
Also ich schwöre, Post und Pilzerboten werden es lieben.
Naja, wobei einige finden nicht mal das Glockensymbol auf meiner Klingel.
Insofern ist das vielleicht ganz gut.
An der Stelle sei gesagt, ich habe leider beide Seiten identisch bedruckt.
Und deswegen sind die Ausschnitte ein bisschen unschön geworden,
weil die markierten Stellen nicht perfekt übereinander liegen.
Beim nächsten Mal würde ich die Ausschnitte dann nur auf der Rückseite drucken.
Dann kann man das Ganze auch direkt mit einem Messer auf dem Glas ausschneiden.
Außerdem kann es sein, dass die Folie sich bei starker Sonneneinstrahlung auch ein bisschen verzieht.
Das fällt ja kaum auf.
Es ist nicht viel, ein bis zwei Millimeter.
Daher am besten etwas größer bestellen und beim Aufkleben vielleicht schon ein bisschen föhnen,
damit die Wärmeeinwirkung schon mal etwas da ist.
Alternativ, wenn man keine Symbole oder Buchstaben drucken will,
kann man das Glas auch einfach mit Farbe von einer Seite ankleben.
Ich würde lieber etwas reinkleben hinten.
Das Ganze dann mit Silikon verkleben und das hält Bombe.
Aber jetzt zur Technik, das ist ja auch an der Stelle das Wichtigste.
Guck mal, sogar mit eigenem Board.
Ich habe mir mit EasyEDA oder alternativ KeyCut Platinen erstellt.
Ist das sein Mikrofon, was er da hat?
Ist das das Mikrofon?
Oder wo ist das Mikrofon?
Spaghetti-Kram selber bauen.
Und das Ganze habe ich bei JLCPCB bestellt.
Und die sind wirklich super günstig, haben echt gute Qualität
und die Lieferung dauert nur wenige Tage.
Insgeheim hätte ich das auch ohne Sponsoring gesagt,
aber wenn nun schon gefragt wird.
Also danke an der Stelle an JLCPCB für das Sponsoring.
Die Klingel nutzt einen ESP32 Kameramodul mit Weitwinkelkamera.
Das gibt es so ungefähr für 7 Euro.
Dann dazu ein 4x20 Zeichen Display,
ein Piezo Piepzer für Audio Feedback.
Da kann man sich zum Beispiel verschiedene Klingeltöne programmieren.
Dann noch ein Touch-Sensor aus Chinesium.
Und das kriegt man dann alles zusammen so für 20 Euro.
Und wo ist Lautsprecher und Mikro?
Das gibt es natürlich auch teurer und mit längerer Lieferzeit bei eurem.
So machst du 500 Euro pro Tag Dropshipper eures Vertrauens.
Aber ich verlinke mal die Teile-Liste im Blog-Artikel.
Der Touch-Sensor funktioniert hintergeliefert.
Wo ist die Teile-Liste?
Also was brauchen wir?
Display, Touch-Sensor, Kamera.
Das kann doch nicht alles sein.
Das ESP32 Kameramodul hat doch keinen.
Moment, kann das sein, dass das gar kein Mikro und keine Gegend ist?
Dass das einfach nur eine Klingel mit Bild ist?
Ach, das ist so eine Klingel mit Bild.
Da ist gar kein Mikro und Sprecher drin.
Ja, dann ist das ja eigentlich komplett für meine Anwendungszwecke useless.
Ja, dann ist das doof.
Ja, das kann man da bestimmt einmal.
Aber das ist natürlich dann doof.
Dann wird es nämlich ein bisschen schwieriger, Sound und sowas mit dem ESP32 zu machen.
MQTT, jawoll.
By the way, das ist der Grund, warum ich kein Node-RED verwende.
Ich finde, sowas kann man in einer ordentlichen Programmiersprache deutlich übersichtlicher und besser programmieren als dieses Ganze.
Ich habe mich ja damit eine Weile mit beschäftigt und habe mir eigentlich eine coole Idee.
Ich programmiere das lieber in gut verständlichem Source-Code als dieses Kästen hier miteinander verbinden.
Damit ich besonders schnell, also direkt beim Klingeln, ein Foto aufs Handy bekomme,
übertrage ich ein nur klein aufgelöstes Bild vom Moment des Auslösens.
Naja, 1,3 Megapixel ist immer noch mehr als mein erstes Foto-Handy hatte.
Das reicht auf jeden Fall, um zu erkennen, wer klingelt.
Und für Gesichtserkennung reicht es auch.
Parallel kann man sich auch ein Video mit Motion Eye aufzeichnen.
Die Bildrate ist allerdings nicht mit einer Action-Kamera zu vergleichen.
Das ist eine FPS.
Ich habe auch verschiedene Bewegungsmelder getestet, wie zum Beispiel ein Infrarot-Sensor oder ein Mikrowellenradar.
Aber das klappt beides nicht so richtig gut.
Meistens kommen immer ein paar Meldungen zu viel.
Wenn zum Beispiel die Sonne auf den Infrarot-Sensor scheint, natürlich sowieso.
Vielleicht liegt das auch an der Position, denn mein 433 MHz Bewegungsmelder, der auch mit Infrarot läuft, klappt als Alternative echt super.
Und eine Anleitung, wie man so einen anbindet, habe ich ja bereits auf meinem Kanal.
Bei Bewegung, die bei genügend Licht auch über Motion Eye und die Kamera erkannt werden kann,
kann man zum Beispiel das Display aktivieren und Gäste begrüßen.
Ich zeige mir da auch direkt die Uhrzeit und Temperatur an.
Richtig praktisch ist es aber, wenn nach dem Klingeln...
Altes Handy einbohren.
Altes Android-Handy kann man da bestimmt auch machen.
... informatisiert Nachrichten angezeigt werden.
Und dazu habe ich mir ein eigenes Bedienfeld in Home Assistant gebaut.
Darüber kann ich Nachrichten auswählen oder selbst erstellen.
Zum Beispiel, dass wir gerade im Garten sind oder den Paket-Modus aktivieren,
damit wird dem Postboten direkt die Garage geöffnet, wo er dann das Paket ablegen kann.
Es ist auch möglich, die Tür über Gesichtserkennung zu öffnen, da Gesichtserkennung...
Okay, Tür öffnen mit Gesichtserkennung ist klar, ganz bestimmt.
Vor allem erkennt er dann ein Bild von dir auch, super.
Ich habe jetzt ja auch meine Tür-Gegensprechanlage aufgerüstet,
mit Möglichkeit ans Handy weiterzuleiten, das Ganze.
Da habe ich ja den Testaufbau hier gezeigt auf Twitter.
Das sah halt sehr testig aus.
Alter, jetzt fuck mich nicht ab.
Es ist halt ein bisschen sehr testaufbaumäßig gewesen.
Mittlerweile habe ich das alles im Keller angeschlossen.
Aber es funktioniert.
Das hier ist analog zu deckt.
Das hier ist das Ding, was den eigentlichen Telefonanruf macht, das ist die Stromversorgung.
Und hier ist es halt angeschlossen an der Tür-Gegensprechanlage.
So, wenn es jetzt klingelt, wählt das Ding meine Telefonnummer an, das hier oben.
Und ich kann entweder an alle Decktelefone im Haus drangehen oder am Handy drangehen.
Und ich kann auch weiter an die Gegensprechanlagen-Geräte drangehen, das funktioniert auch.
Ich habe es jetzt so eingestellt, dass es an den Telefonen nur einmal klingelt oder zweimal schnell hintereinander klingelt,
dass es dann nicht nervt, wenn du beispielsweise hier an die Tür-Gegensprechanlage gehst und es im Hintergrund die ganze Zeit bimmelt.
Das war relativ easy, weil ich konnte einfach auf meinen Decktelefon einen neuen Custom-Klingelton einspielen.
Da kann man einen Klingelton einstellen, der bis zu 30 Sekunden lang ist.
Also habe ich einen Custom-Klingelton gemacht, der einfach nur zweimal klingeln enthält und danach 27 Sekunden Ruhe.
Und nach 30 Sekunden bricht das Ding eh ab.
Das heißt, es klingelt einer unten, dann macht das Telefon bim-bim-bim, dann macht 2-3 Sekunden später die Decktelefone bim-bim-bim und mein Handy.
Das ist wirklich sehr praktisch.
Das nächste, was ich jetzt noch versuchen werde, ist, da muss ich mal gucken, ob ich da mit meinen Media-Programmierskills hinkomme.
Ich habe mir überlegt, ich könnte das Kamerabild von meiner Kamera nehmen plus den Telefonanruf.
Also ich programmiere was, was ich an der Fritzbox als neues Telefon anmelde.
Und da nehme ich den Telefonanruf an und nehme das Bild von der Kamera, mache daraus einen neuen Zip-Telefonanruf und rufe mich auf dem Handy an.
Also das müsste ich quasi selbst zusammen programmieren.
Also ich müsste quasi ein Programm basteln, was auf der einen Seite den Telefonanruf annimmt, auf der anderen Seite den Kamerastream nimmt, das zusammenpackt und daraus einen neuen Telefonanruf macht, den es dann mir ans Handy schickt.
Und dann könnte ich quasi über ein Zip-Programm auf dem Handy quasi den Anruf bekommen, multiplex quasi mit meinem Kamerabild.
Wenn das funktioniert, mal gucken, ob ich das gebacken kriege, sowas.
Da bin ich mal gespannt drauf.
Ja gut, mehr müssen wir uns zeigen.
Zeig mal her.
Echt sicher Passwort.
Liegt, Leute, liegt.
Übrigens, wir müssen demnächst wieder ein bisschen ESP32, AD410 schaut auch gut aus.
Ja, es gibt einige Dinge, die man verwenden kann.
Es gibt einige Dinge, die man verwenden kann.
Warum ich das so gemacht habe, ist ganz einfach.
Ich wollte die Gegensprechanlage weiter verwenden, die schon im Haus installiert ist und wollte keine neue Klingel hinhängen.
Was ist diese Web-Application 11?
Das ist dieses Ding, mit dem ich hier euch Emotes einblende.
Ich habe auf dem zweiten Monitor eine Web-Interface mit den Emotes.
Das ist die Web-Anwendung, die das macht.
Diese Geschichte.
Das wollte ich jetzt gerade auch sagen.
Vielleicht kriege ich das gebacken, das zu programmieren.
Ach ja, genau.
Es kann sein, dass wir demnächst noch ein bisschen ESP32 C++ machen müssen, weil ich habe gelesen, es gibt jetzt Arduino 2.0.0 für ESP32.
Was endlich, endlich, endlich mal eine neue Version hat.
Ist das jetzt der High-Speed-Gif-Player?
Nein, immer noch nicht.
Ich habe hier noch nicht weiter gemacht.
Es gibt jetzt hier eine Testversion von 2.0 irgendwo.
Das wollte ich mal ausprobieren hier.
Arduino 2.0 für ESP32, weil die haben es endlich mal geschafft, ihr Framework zu aktualisieren unten drunter.
Arduino für ESP32 ist ja nun ein Aufsatz auf diesem ESP-IDF.
ESP-IDF ist das eigentliche SDK-Programmierumgebung für ESP32.
Arduino ist nun ein Modul oben drauf, um es mit Arduino kompatibel zu machen.
Die haben jetzt endlich, endlich ihr Framework unten drunter mal aktualisiert mit Arduino 2.0.
Da gibt es ein paar coole neue Sachen, die muss ich mal ausprobieren.
Man kann jetzt zum Beispiel C++20 verwenden, standardmäßig.
Also Standard C++20, was es eigentlich besser macht.
Das ist halt C++.
Es ist nach wie vor scheiße, aber es ist vielleicht ein bisschen erträglicher an manchen Stellen.
Einfach Platform-My-O nehmen, so einfach ist das nicht.
Platform-My-O hat das beispielsweise noch gar nicht drin.
Du kannst Platform-My-O nehmen mit einem Custom Package.
Das mache ich ja auch dafür.
Was man da nimmt, ob Arduino, IDE oder Platform-My-O ist ja letztendlich wurscht.
Mit einem Custom Package kannst du es auch mit Platform-My-O nehmen.
Aber aktuell hat offiziell Platform-My-O immer noch die 1er-Version drin.
So, und das ist halt echt ganz cool.
Gerade, dass der Unterbau neu ist.
Bin ich mal gespannt, muss man mal gucken.
Du hast ja zum Beispiel einen WebSocket Server dabei und sowas, was du vorher nicht hattest.
Du kannst neuen C++ Standard verwenden.
Gib ein paar Sachen.
Muss ich sagen, klingt eigentlich ganz sinnvoll.
Müssen wir uns irgendwann demnächst mal angucken.
Chat.
Ich würde sagen, ich gehe jetzt was futtern.
Und dann schalte ich das Video frei auf YouTube.
Gibt es irgendjemanden, den wir hosten können?
Lost ist am Start.
Virus ist am Start.
Wie könnte man denn hosten?
Jetzt sind erst alle gehostet.
Also Leute, wir sehen uns.
Vielleicht heute Abend, vielleicht auch morgen erst.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
Bis denn.
Machts gut.
See you.